[Music]
and welcome back to the podcast rich
it's a pleasure to be official happy to
resume our ongoing conversation
welcome to Los Angeles it's a beautiful
day here in LA I know you love it so
much you're you're gonna move here I'm
gonna make that happen
I'm literally I'm thinking about doing
that's my website listen babe you know I
think we should really think about this
yeah it's pretty great right related
cause this morning on the beach right I
didn't have anything for two hours and
so I spoke to my PA for like literally
an hour whilst walking on the beach and
that's not fully embracing the nature
but I thought this is pretty nice yeah
it's good and what's cool about kind of
watching you over the last year with the
podcast and all the work that you're
doing is there's a lot of overlap like I
feel like almost every uk-based guest
that I've had on the show is a friend of
yours or here come on your show we have
you know Jim Newman and Ross Edgeley and
we should talk about Tony riddle because
it just thought it just yesterday he
finished his 30 days of running
essentially 30 miles a day barefoot from
south to north
yeah incredible I mean it's available we
both had Tony on our shows and you know
I've known Tony for a few years and I
love what he does I love what he stands
for I think what he puts out that I
guess is quite out there for a lot of
people but I think we can all learn from
that and you can take a little snippet
from that if you want an appliance your
own life I'm literally working on my
barefoot running like I wear barefoot
shoes we're all about the vivos I am I
love the man I I really do that they've
changed my life for sure well the thing
about Tony is that it may be out there
but basically he's he's attempting to
get people to hearken back to you know a
for con era where these things were not
out there but basically just how we
lived that's all he's doing with he's
getting back see what we have done for
the bulk of our revolution for sure but
what fascinates me about Tony's journey
because I've been following it like
yourself I was meant to go running with
him on I don't know day seven day eight
and then we were gonna record a live
event wise he's trying to do podcast
almost every day along the way yeah
exactly so talk about filling his
schedule you know running all day yeah
bringing his kids and his wife with him
and recording podcasts but when I spoke
to him we didn't actually get to run
together a couple of reasons for that
but a few days in Tony had come across a
problem you know his feet were swollen
that were really painful he couldn't put
them down and we actually we not
released it yet but we actually spoke
live that evening about how is he
dealing with that how was you know this
big thing he's put out to the world I am
gonna run 30 miles a day for 30 days
yeah maybe day six something I can't put
weight through my foot right you know
and on many levels I think that is a
stress or it's kind of like what am I
doing this for I told everyone that I'm
gonna do this I mean building up for
this for years I've been on national
media talking about it do I need to pull
out and so I really enjoyed that
conversation about how do you deal with
adversity and that was early on that was
early on yeah and around day maybe I
don't know in the mid mid 20s he really
started to have big problems and I don't
know if you saw the images of his feet
but they were like it looked like he had
elephantitis they were so swollen up
like balloons yeah and he had I think he
took one day off maybe or he took a
little bit of a break and the thought
that went through my mind was look man I
know you've got you know people watching
you and you put this pressure on
yourself but there's a difference
between the tenacity required to push
through difficulties to kind of you know
access that inner potential and that
untapped reservoir of what we're all
capable of and then there's just not
being smart I mean I looked at his feet
I was like you shouldn't be on your feet
at all and one day off isn't gonna
change it so I had serious concerns and
reservations about him continuing yeah I
think I think it was about two days off
he took in the end and he thought you
know take a few days off recover
recuperates use the eyes use the
breathing do what you can but still I
agree I was thinking you know if that
was a patient in my clinic oh you'd be
like forget it exactly you'd be write
him a note saying you're off work you
stay at home so from that perspective
it's fascinating but what I was keen to
probe him on actually is you've come
with your wife you come with your kids
you're clearly very disappointed that
this happens you know it's it's clearly
you know on a guttural level that is
frustrating you know if I had set out to
do something like that it'd be like you
know I've got to tell the world now that
I can't do this but I was really
intrigued as to how he deals with that
with his kids around him like did he
have you know like I often I think put
pressure on myself as a father I'm kind
of figuring that out I'm learning to let
go and just accept things a lot more
which has been for sure a process of a
deep process of inner work and in a
discovery but I'm super intrigued this a
did he feel a pressure in front of his
kids to demonstrate adversity happens in
life how am I going to handle this and I
found that super super fascinating is I
think he did I'm sure he did there's no
question that he did and here's another
thought his whole thing is that were
born dab it to run barefoot right yeah
but here he is with basically
elephantitis on his feet which is you
know you gotta say like this is this is
this is sort of detracting from his core
thesis like if your feet look like that
maybe you should depression right yeah
that's the idea pressure but this is my
thing this is what my my whole thing
that I'm putting out to the world is
around this sort of natural way of
living but hey all credits are the guy
did it because he did it right yeah I
had some text with him this morning
super proud of him so yeah yeah and on
the subject of vivo barefoot shoes we
have to talk about your your new
fascination with swimwear like you've
gotten it you got yourself in a wetsuit
and overcame your fears did this race
and now like this is kind of your thing
yeah I mean I think if I'm honest rich I
think you've played some role in that
journey for me from you know I'm not
genuinely not to saying this you know I
listen to your podcast I really enjoy it
I find it I'll give me the best podcasts
out there in terms of
what connects with me where I'm at in my
life and what I want to listen to
especially given that I don't really
listen to many health and wellness
podcasts anymore because you know I do
that so I don't really want to be I
don't either because it just it feels
like homework yeah it doesn't work you
know and I actually don't really
consider my podcast a health and
wellness podcast frankly anymore I think
it's not either I think it's I don't you
actually know how I would define it it's
a I don't know it's it's an everything
podcast yeah but to come back to your
question about swimrun you know what
I've always been a pretty fit guy I
think but I never did endurance sport
you know I did a little you know I was
always about you know I'm gonna do 10
minutes of bodyweight exercises today in
my kitchen every day but I never really
did endurance so what happened is over
the past few years I'm changing you know
I am I'm doing a ton of deep work on
myself and as part of that what I
thought my desires were and one who
wanted to do it's not what I thought it
used to be so that sounds really kind of
quite vague so swimrun I saw when you
did it
I've been because I am a fan of Eva
beffort shoes and I have become friends
with those guys and you know that's a
whole nother story in itself they're one
of the big sponsors of your show too
recently now on the show yeah but the
world series yeah sure yeah and so they
invited me to not one of the till till
oh I don't know how you pronounce it
officially brand there was a guy who
came to my live event the other night
from Sweden and he corrected my
pronunciation I thought I'd finally
gotten it how are you I was going give
me your best shot today which is close
but not it's definitely not it
don't even try just call it Otello and
we'll just be you know we know what
we're talking about speaking Nimrods but
so they invited me
they invited me last year actually to
their inaugural one so this was their
own invite-only retreats that they were
putting on in this vivo did right yeah a
fever days and I remember because Ross
was there too
Ross was there exactly and I couldn't go
last year in October for a variety of
reasons so it didn't work out this year
they gave me advance
they said we're gonna do this summer
solstice in June wrong with love ISA
Khan I said yeah okay guys no race I've
got I've got plenty of time I'm gonna
train I'm gonna figure this out I think
I called you once when you're in New
York yeah very kind of game with some
time and gave me a few tips on what I
needed to do because I'm not really a
swimmer
I'm not really a runner like an
endurance runner so it was the week and
this event was on the Saturday and I'd
been noticing that I have a super-busy
unlike my book came out of the UK I'll
be doing the talked and all the kind of
crazy stuff that we're all doing now
when we're in the public eye and I
thought this is nuts I can't really do
this on Saturday like I haven't trained
I've hardly swamp I've certainly never
swum in open water so I thought I you
know I know my fern DUP a guy called
Nick who sort of works erofeev I said
hey Nick look we're coming to the event
you know you said we can come now with a
family we put the flights my wife me my
two kids we're gonna come we're looking
forward to seeing Devon I don't know
that part of the world I don't think I
can compete my if I'm honest because
I'll be too busy man I've been
overworked I'm not trained and he was
great and he said listen if you have a
desire wrong and to do this at some
point this is the best place to start
we've got safety boats everywhere you'll
be absolutely fine any problems we'll
pull you out I thought okay all right
fine I mean what's there right so I
think I didn't understand what it was I
know someone swimmer was I didn't you I
knew what it was in the sense that I
know you swim and you run right I knew
that much but I don't really know the
feeling I didn't know the training for
it anyway so that let's fast forward to
Saturday it's Saturday morning and I
didn't sleep that well I was pretty
nervous you know the night before like
people from Sweden who like came second
and the main event we're talking and I'm
like watching these guys and you know
everyone's gonna you know to me everyone
is pretty confident they've done this
stuff before they know what they're
doing I'm thinking all right you've
always pushed yourself and let's see
what happens I think I'll be okay so I
wake up I am opening the box for the
first time with my new hoop wetsuit
right I am not even tried it on yeah so
let's this is this is how I'm prepared I
was I'm taking it off
I put it on I'm just struggling to get
this thing on a mic this is pretty tight
like should they be this tight man I
know you live in California right you
wear wet suits if you have never worn
one before you don't know what it should
feel like right so I'm I mean I think
you saw that photo I post on Instagram
like is this what a wetsuit should look
like right so I put it on things a bit
type and hit okay well I don't really
have another option anyway and put my
shoes on and then I meet where we meant
to meet and we now go on a chair like we
we have to get a coach with the other
competitors to the start so we get on
the coach I've got my goggles on my head
got my swim cap on I've got my white
suit and wearing my shoes walk on
everyone's got all this other gear
around them like people have got like
paddles and the paddles pulpit at there
like the whole thing and I'm initially
thinking I don't get this what's going
on I think okay look it's probably easy
that you don't know anything about that
keeps us simple in your head just go
that now look I looked at the theater I
didn't do the kind of ultra type
distance I did the sort of medium one
there I think it's a sprint one they
call it mm-hmm and I'm looking at it and
I'm thinking okay first swim 250 meters
okay look I can swim that under pool now
yes I normally stop after every 50
meters for a little breather but I
reckon I could get through 250 meters
then there's a 2.5 k run then there's a
600 meter swim like I think a 6k 11.2 K
swim downstream and a 3k run so I
thought point UK that's legit that I
said yeah it was downstream to be fair
but so so here's what happens I meet my
partner and they they partnered me up
with someone who's very experienced I so
don't worry wrong we'll have someone
who's super experienced anyway we start
it's cold
number one right it is freezing I go in
I'm like yeah god this is so cold I
think okay come on you could do this I
said we start swimming and I remember so
clearly we must have only gone about 100
meters and then I suddenly became aware
that I can't see the bottom like I know
this sounds obvious but I'm suddenly
aware in my head I can't see the bottom
of it
like the pool I cannot see the bottom I
start to panic I stop to breathe fast
I wouldn't swim I started to you know
have a very mild sort of panic attack
you need a distress solution I needed a
stress solution you're ready to Pillar
but I did not have one I did not have
one so so I'm there and then of what I
do my my partner Dave I grab I grab hold
of him like I'm like Dave Dave I can't
do this is that wrong look just relax
take some deep breaths
lie on your back you will flow in your
wetsuits right I think that was one of
the things I told you when you called me
I was like if you just get freaked out
you'll you'll float just roll on your
back and it's a shame that in that
moment my rational player wasn't able to
draw these things in and I said to him
there's no in my head I'm thinking there
is no way in hell I'm lying on my back
like I am panicked I didn't have
confidence I would then float
anyway so listen I'm thinking at that
time if we get to the end if I get to
the end as tuned to 50 meters when I get
to the end of this tuna 50 meters there
is no way in hell I'm getting back in
this ocean this is exactly what I was
feeling
anyway I altum Utley managed to get to
the end right get that and anything okay
like it's only 2.5 cave and that's run I
can do that easy no problem let's just
do the run so did the run I'm feeling
really tired doing it cuz I think I'd
expended a lot of nervous energy with
all that panic then I get there and now
we've got the 600 meter swim and it
looks as though it's really away from
the ocean like like quite far like you
have to swim through this gorgeous arch
and I looked and I thought come on wrong
and you can do this come on you've just
done that if you can swim 250 just take
your time stay calm you've been through
it you can do it and it was quite lucky
because I started to go out I can
remember so clearly you could still
stand up by the start then after about
100 metres the ocean the floor seems to
come up again where you could stand up
again so I thought okay I'm just gonna
stand here because I can and my
partner's like are you okay you okay I'm
like you can't find I've just seen
there's an opportunity for me to stand
and just get my breath I'm just gonna
take it anyway I go I finish it I go and
complete the whole race
I feel literally like I've won the
lottery I feel
I don't think I felt that feeling of joy
exhilaration pride and I was just this
is one of the most amazing things I have
ever done and I mean you can unpack that
if you want but for me that was my first
experience of swimrun I love that I have
now become obsessed uh-huh
I now it's all I think about I watched
swimming instructional videos on YouTube
every single nights I'm like doing the
classic I'm all-in now I'm working on my
stroke I'm like oh should it be this
angle should be 90 degrees when it's
comfortable like a hundred degrees I'm
I'm literally obsessed with swimming and
then the summer so I don't live near the
ocean right so I go back to my urban
setting near Manchester in the UK I'm
starting going to the pool and have
starts off July when my kids were off we
put two last-minute holiday tollens
Rossy in the Canary Islands and we go
there and I'm thinking you know what
I've not swim in the ocean for six weeks
we're on an island and I started
googling for open water swimming nearby
you know I didn't me didn't have the
conference just go and swim of the ocean
by myself and I found this guy called
Paul who I think is regarded as one of
the best swimming teachers around he's
been out there for 25 years phoned him
up lovely guy said just come down to our
we do open with the ocean swimming every
every Tuesday morning comes to the group
says I got like hey man I can't come to
the group like can I have a one-on-one
he's that won't just come to the group I
see what you like don't worry so I go
anyway within two days he has me
swimming out from the coastline 250
meters out of tune or 15 meters back
like in minutes without even thinking
about it he was such a good teacher are
you you fast-forward to the end of the
summer in August and I went back to
Devon back to the place of my fear and
Galahad who's the CEO of vive before he
said mate we're gonna swim around the
island I'm like hey you know 13 months
ago I couldn't get in the water I said
how far is it he said it's about 1.5 k
around there anyway after three days of
being there we went out I saw him 1.5 k
round this island it was one of the most
peaceful experiences of my life there
were little rock channels
I saw wildlife
and I just felt a live man so yeah I
mean wait you want to go with school
right I love it
that's amazing so are you signed up for
another race yeah well you know we're in
California so I got here on Tuesday and
I was a bit jet-lagged I didn't sleep
much on that night but I know that these
guys as part of my YouTube exploration
I've come across tower 26 oh yeah Jerry
Jerry and I know they do a Wednesday
morning ocean swim in Santa Monica I'm
staying with my buddy true in Santa
Monica I was lying about at 4:30
thinking I'm knackered
I did my HRV on my phone should I always
do when I thought it is tanked
you don't want forget it I'm just gonna
go to the ocean so I went and I joined
these guys I didn't do the whole session
but I did 750 meters there I'm great
yeah it was awesome and so am I signed
up yet I'm gonna do Malta are you doing
Malta Duty Malta I know your buddy runs
yes so John Shaw who is a friend of of
ours who came on our him and his wife
came on our Italy retreat and Curto rego
well I think it's I think John I don't
know if he's the race director or
organizer but he's sort of the point
person on the island who's in charge of
yeah I'm sure this thing gets pulled off
and when I was in Malta recently I went
out with their day ever oh my sort of
feel great by soreness - yeah there's
like 10 guys and they get together like
a couple morning's a week and they swim
around around the islands it's fantastic
you're gonna love it
I'm also gonna do can now mmm so
literally one week ago Galahad text me
and said hey man we're going out it's a
can but got a villa
there's spare beds there do you want to
come out now here's the challenge to me
my favorite artist in the world's at
this moment in time is John Mayer right
I love I love his lyrics I love his
music
I love his bands I have seen every tour
when he's ever been in the UK now on the
Friday nights before the can events I
spent a lot of time probably too much
money getting four very good seats
for the John Mayer concert in Manchester
and I thought this would be great
because my kids like John Mayer is well
maybe this would be a really great first
gig for us all together the four of us
go near the front we watched on their
play this is how much I've changed is
that from
now even one year ago I would not miss
that John Mayer gig for anything but for
me now it's like if I'm honest I'd
rather get the can for the weekend
I'd rather spend that weekend the
weekend in nature I want to get back in
the ocean I want my kids to experience
that and so I'm canning the gig and I'm
gonna see where sacrifices we made hey
Matt I get it's a personal note on the
chopping block for swim run but you know
what it's great it's cool no it's super
awesome to see you take to that like
that and I love how swim run is growing
and becoming this thing I will say this
when I was in Malta and I and I went and
worked out with those guys
we were we were attacked by a swarm of
jellyfish like a larger conversation
about the environment and the
acidification of our coastal waters
because I think it has a lot to do with
the fact that a lot of the you know
marine wildlife is is being decimated
because of the degradation of the
environment which now allows jellyfish
to proliferate and we were out in this
Bay just it was there was no way out I
mean it was a massive swarm and everyone
says darting for the shore and we all
got bit and the I've been bit by
jellyfish quite a bit like in Hawaii
like you know I know what it feels like
I've managed it but this was like a
whole different thing
and I got bit on my wrist and I don't
know if you can see that this was in May
and I have like a permanent scar here
don't mess up quite quite hopefully this
time of year that won't be a problem so
that was in Volta that was in Malta yeah
those guys go out like every day it
doesn't seem to be an issue so I think
you're gonna be fine
Hey look it is now it's gonna live in
your head I feel bad for you I know man
you can tell I like moving towards
things that I can't do I know if I
reflect my heart my heart my own
personality traits I'd say that there's
probably something I've always done a
little bit I kind of like that I really
do strongly feel that that's that's what
you grow right so form
to go swimmin was just a word I knew I
sort of had seen it a bit online I was
interested but now it's changed my life
right what I love about it for me is
that the events seem to all be done in
harmony with a natural environment yes
that's the thing that's super cool about
it there's no plastic of these events
it's super cool the people are great
that appears to be from what I've seen
in my limited experience not that much
of a competitive element to it as you
may get a triathlon and again this is
just a perception but I think it's
accurate I mean it's still it's
competitive in its competition but it's
a different it's a completely different
environment the relationship to the
competitive aspect of that is very
different it's very grounded in in in
nature is very participatory in general
and it's yeah people want to win and all
of that but it's really not about that
it's about this shared experience yeah
and so what am i doing with that is one
of my best buddies a guy called Jeremy
who lives in Bristol which is I don't
know 150 miles away from me we both have
got this calling to do swim run so we've
we're gonna try do three or four rents a
year together now we can't train worthy
together which of course from a
competitive element may be an issue but
it's also a way that we can actually see
each other right and do something fun
together and not just you know hang out
on a cafe when we get together or
something you know do something so we're
super stoked and excited that actually
we might be able to do this together now
my son because he's seen me do this why
he now what says daddy could you know
maybe I can do one of these with you and
I know vivo are going to do a kid Swan
next year at their event as well and I'm
thinking for me I mean circling back to
what we said with Tony
I very much I very much that would the
way one of the motivations for me to
complete that race right on a very deep
level I'm sure was that my kids were
there right they knew that Daddy was
gonna do this one run event now it
doesn't mean there's anything wrong with
saying hey you know what guys I was too
scared I couldn't do it
right something wrong with that but I
also felt wouldn't it be lovely to show
my children that actually it's okay to
be scared of something it's okay to lean
into that and see what happens and it's
just
hey man I'm trying to do the best I can
like every parent right I don't know if
I am yeah but that was also a slight
motivation for me yeah it's great that
hasn't worked with my kids like I did
they don't care at all but if you try to
force them into it no I've no definitely
not definitely not I mean I think on
some level it registers but it's not
it's not as if they're saying hey
they're not tip toeing towards it
they're just like that's dad's thing you
know which is fine they have their own
stuff hey
exactly but did you a meeting grow up in
California no so this whole love of the
ocean I mean is that a new thing since
you moved here no I've always loved the
ocean and I love summer and the beaches
and all that kind of stuff it's
interesting when when what I've noticed
living in California is that kids that
grow up here don't develop that same
affinity for it because it's always
there like when I was a kid when we got
to go to the beach that was like a big
deal like I would I would do anything to
go to the beach like it was super
exciting and exotic and and something
you only got to do a couple times a year
but when you live here like my my kids
are like we don't want to go to the
beach but this isn't that I I don't know
if I guess it's not the same with
everything like when something's on our
doorstep we don't really appreciate yeah
we take it for granted yeah and I a few
nights ago I was with my friends my
buddy drew who I'm staying with we went
to see some of his friends in Venice and
we were just hanging out and in his
friends place in the evening and I asked
them all I said hey guys look
you are literally two blocks from the
ocean like I am literally all I think
about the moment is getting to the ocean
we can we go to the beach no I I just
said how often I said to you guys do you
guys go regularly to the ocean you know
I don't like we're actually done we've
not been there anything weeks and it was
really telling for me that hey this is
super fascinating isn't it but these
guys they live here they're not going
because it's there all the time and then
you know that's how busy our lives are
right and we don't often myself included
appreciate there's a lot of things
appreciate business about where we are
we always you know I travel too you know
for me it's a holidays when I'm at the
beach or in the ocean I'm like getting
not as frustrated as I might have done
in the past but you know all day on
Sunday it was a beautiful day I could
see the ocean but I'm in an office in
4th Street recording podcasts all day
now I get it that's work although
frankly to call it work seems ridiculous
since I enjoy it so much but it is I
mean I've been really really wrestling
with this this week this whole idea of
nature the ocean do you move out if you
move out and near the ocean do you just
start getting busy in your own life and
therefore it is something that you might
do when when your friends visit and they
want to go see ok Hey look we've got
this beautiful beach here I don't know I
haven't figured it out yet but I'm
really been cool to nature these days
yeah well I think all of this dovetails
perfectly into the things that you care
about and you talk about and the subject
matter and themes of you know the book
the stress solution which is about
reconnecting and what Tony talks about
to like reconnecting with nature and you
know prioritizing time for your
friendships and intimacy and touch and
you know physical exercise and
mindfulness and disconnecting from our
digital lives and all of these things
for sure I don't think it's unrelated I
think hey what do they say that you
often write the book that you need to
write for yourself right I would
absolutely accept that that was probably
the case for writing this book you know
I can say it was I was writing it for
patients and because this is what a
problem that I see and of course that is
one of the reasons but I think on some
deeper level it was like look I need to
get on top of this I need to figure this
stuff out myself
and yeah as you say a lot of the themes
that are in the book all the themes
we've just spoken about because they are
universal themes of what I think makes a
healthy happy human being I don't think
it's separate at all this is about
stress or this is now about nutrition or
boomers actually it's all part of the
same thing and this is as we were saying
I think if we set it off air or on air
the whole idea of what we do in our
podcasts which is it's quite hard to
define because it's not one thing you
know I almost find it limiting to call
minor health and wellness podcasts and
everything podcasts er how to live your
best life podcast like very much yours
is so though I don't want to pigeonhole
yours
so that mean I actually when when Apple
podcast changed their categories eirick
mine off of health and wellness and put
it into education for that reason Wow
because I wanted to broaden that
spectrum a little bit because I don't
think you know yeah I do a lot of health
and wellness and fitness stuff on my
show but I think to define it as such is
not really accurate yeah you know yeah I
agree I totally agree the larger point
being that we can look at these things
in isolation nutrition sleep you know
fitness and all of these different
sectors that all contribute to the
well-being of a human being but
ultimately it is the synergy between
these things and taking a more holistic
you know 10,000 foot view on how we're
living our lives that is really the most
important thing like if you have your
diet completely 100% dialed in but you
can't sleep at night or you don't get
along with your boss or you know you're
you're staring at your phone all day
how healthy are you and that's you know
something I've said many times before on
this podcast but in order to truly be at
your full potential you have to find a
way to balance all of these disciplines
and you know it's it's it's hard it's
not easy but to but to take them at
piecemeal I think is is missing a larger
opportunity and I think this is some of
the content that we covered when I was
on the for the first time because my
first book I again it covers food
movement sleep stress all these pieces
but I couldn't really it just felt wrong
to me to focus on one area because I
believe health is a combination of all
these various things and I I think I
really furthered that idea with this
book I really feel that the kind of the
two books fit together this is a
progression am i more proud of this book
I don't know on one level yeah cuz I
don't think I could have written this
book three or four years ago I think I
was able to the relationship section of
it is probably probably the part of it
I'm proud of stuff like I think it's
that and the meaning of purpose section
I think it possibly to areas that people
may not have been expecting
and I think they potentially offer the
most value for people in there I'm proud
of the other sections but I think
relationships I think and the erosion of
our relationships the fact that we are
so busy all the time people don't
prioritize our relationships even the
relations that we do have when we are
with those people often we're not
present often we disconnect it often we
are physically in the same space
geographically we are together but in
our heads we can be millions of miles
away because we're on our devices or
we're distracted by what we've got to do
you know or you you know you come home
from work in your car and you stop and
as you get out you pulled out your phone
and check your emails and then your you
check Instagram and as you're walking in
you are also checking that there's
something your daughter comes out and
actually you're not present there you're
still thinking about that and I think
these things sound small they are so so
important having close nourishing
relationships is one of the best ways to
de-stress but ironically having too much
stress in your life I think makes it
very hard to help those close nourishing
relationships yeah there's no question
about it you know I think it's super
important and it and it leaves me you
know doing an inventory of you know my
personal relationships outside of you
know you know my marriage and my kids
but with my friendships like so I found
myself in a situation where a lot of
people I consider friends like yourself
our relationship is based on doing
podcasting together it's like like I
feel bonded to you but we've never spent
any time went off mic you know what I
mean like it's it's there's something
not right about that and as I was you
know preparing to speak to you today I
was going over your book again and I'm
going through it I'm like I think I
think your your talent and your genius
is your ability to take all of this
information that's out there and
synthesize it and then present it in an
incredibly accessible and digestible way
like taking concepts that are perhaps
confusing if you get into the weeds on
them and just
just drilling down to the essentials and
presenting the most important aspects of
them so that people can actually fully
understand and implement these things in
their lives and I'm looking at him like
yeah I know that I know it's like it's
I'm reading it I'm like there were there
were certain things that were brand-new
to me that I want to talk to you about
that I thought were super fascinating
but a lot of it is like I know all this
stuff and yet here I am a week and a
half ago two weeks ago I was in
Nantucket I did two conversations on
stage which was amazing and super
gratifying and incredible came back
last-minute preparations for this live
event which which we have to talk about
the fact that you said you were gonna
come and you do well let's talk about
later but hold on a second we'll circle
back to that and had that experience
which was unbelievable but also like a
tremendous amount of work and stress and
anxiety you know inducing now doing this
with you and then tomorrow morning I
have a 7:00 a.m. flight going to
Telluride to do another conference it's
like it's a lot and I'm trying to be a
husband and a parent and and learn how
to manage a team of people and I'm like
I haven't made time for my friends or
called this person back I've just I've
been grinding you know and I'm tired and
even though I understand all these
principles that you speak about in the
book and I agree with all of them if I'm
honest with myself I'm I'm not
practicing them very well first of all I
appreciate your compliments about the
book and and what I try and do with them
because you know that is something when
I'm sitting down to write I'm always
thinking hard about my audience I'm
thinking what exactly is gonna help
convert the knowledge into action what
is I'm not interested in writing a book
everyone reads and then nobody does
anything on that on the back of it I'm
not saying it's easy to write book like
that but I've read many books are that
way it's like yeah okay fine
I get all that it's nice to read I feel
inspired but I'm not gonna go and do
anything so in my head I'm thinking how
can you take these deep concepts how can
you simplify to the bareness
see and then give an actionable
achievable solution for someone that
they might feel you don't want I can
probably do that and you actually if I'm
honest you've got to put your ego to the
side a little bit because I certainly
found this with my first book as well
but also this book that there's a
tendency at times to go I want to show
people I know you know I know more I
know way more depth than this but my
editor was great for this as well I give
credit where it's due
it was a case of like this is not a book
for you to show off your knowledge this
is a book to help every single reader
that's the goal and so you got a I found
I had to put my ego to the side and go
it's not about showing off is there a
clear narrative have you made the case
well enough have you inspired them so
they feel that this is achievable for
them that's a key one for me I work as a
dots of rich with patients from all
different backgrounds wealthy people
affluent people but also people without
much money I spent a lot of time into
private communities and I'm very
passionate but actually we should be
giving health information to people that
is applicable to everyone you know we
are living you know I'm staying as Santa
Monica this week what is its the
wellness capsule of the world right you
walk around well I went to air one on
the way here to grab lunch right it's
easy to buy a healthy lunch but I
probably dropped $42 that I'm thinking
it's not cheap but everyone know right
again I'm not criticizing I'm just
saying that is not accessible to many
people so what I try and do I think what
is the most important thing here and
what is the action point
so you mentioned friendship that you're
not making time for your friends I think
a lot of guys get into that position
where they get busy with their career I
think it probably affects men more than
women although I can't say that in all
cases and many of my male friends as
we've got busier as we have gotten to
our 30s and our 40s and mortgage and
family and work commitments we often
don't spend time with our friends many
of us are lucky to have friends but we
don't prioritize because what happens we
see what they're doing on social media
we see where they've been on holiday you
feel like you know that I feel like
you've been spending time yeah I feel
like we spending time with you because I
listen to you in my
when I'm doing something else most weeks
so I feel hey I know rich Mike
I've seen what he's doing on Instagram
and iNSYS Tories I've watched a YouTube
video and on one level I generally do
feel that I know you but on another
level it's like you're right we've not
spent that much face-to-face time I
would like to unpack that cuz I think
it's not always necessary but to
illustrate how important I think it is
let me say I mean there's a patient I
saw 37 year old chap so this guy is
self-employed he has got a successful
business he works for himself he drives
a sports car you know he is from the
outside he's very successful he is
working late every nights he's doing
emails at the weekends he's going go go
go comes in to see me says hey dr. Joshi
look I find it hard to get I bet
sometimes in the morning I'm struggling
to concentrate sometimes I'll just sit
there and I'll feel nothing
I get tearful from time to time is this
what depression is and I said okay look
let's try figure out what's going on so
I'm asking him various aspects about his
life finding out what's going on
what does he do what are his passions
what are his hobbies you know how long
has he felt like this etc etc I do a few
tests everything's normal and then it
becomes quite clear to me that this guy
never sees anybody that he's friends
with and he's quite lucky in the sense
that he lives in the village where he
grew up so what does that mean a lot of
his friends live nearby to him but he
was saying well you know I see whether
I'd see you know I see I see what they
dump on social media this is not an anti
social media piece right but he thought
because he's seeing them he's seen why
they've gone he's seen pictures of their
kids he sees what they had for dinner
last night right this is the madness but
he doesn't see that so I said look would
you consider for the next six weeks this
suggestion what I would like you to do
is at least once a week I would like you
to see one of your friends in person and
when you're wid then I'd love you
support your phones away and really be
present for that interaction now he was
pretty desperate right he was at that
point where he was open to what I had to
offer
and he said yeah sure okay I'll give
that a go he goes away maybe five or six
weeks later he comes back and I asked
him how he doing he said I'll see Ashley
I feel like a different person I'm
feeling good my energies come back I'm
concentrating at work I've got that
spark back in my life I want to say
thank you now I then said to him what's
going on you know what did you do with
your friends he said look well the first
time we played five-a-side football and
I was super fun but after that all we
did is every Sunday morning I'd get
together with at least one of my friends
in our local cafe and we would chew the
facts over a latte so the question then
for me is and I would ask the listeners
who are hearing this story to think
about is did this guy have a mental
health problem right he certainly had
symptoms that were consistent with a
mental health problem or did he have a
deficiency of friendship in his life and
when that friendship deficiency got
corrected other things in his life came
back online no I have seen this pattern
rich over and over again I am NOT trying
to say in every case it is that simple
it is clearly not but I think that's a
very powerful example of somebody who
literally had a friendship deficiency
when he corrected that things got better
and we know you know the science
supports all of this what is it that the
research is suggesting that being lonely
the feeling of being lonely it's as
harmful smoking 15 cigarettes a day I
mean when I go and talk about this in
companies about wellness and I ask
people that says does that surprise you
I mean pretty much everyone's got their
hands up saying yeah how could that be
and then I explained that once you
understand what the stress response is
when you understand what it is doing
everything in your life starts to become
clear hmm so two million years ago
you're in your hunter-gatherer tribe or
let's say you are not in your hands
together tribe actually you are separate
from the tribe your body is smart your
body is trying to prepare you for what
might happen your body knows you are
vulnerable to attack so it activates
your stress response your immune system
gets rounds up your body becomes
inflamed all of these things are smart
things
because if you then do get attacked
you're ready you're not gonna die you've
got your best chance of survival fast
forward now to 2019 and we've got a
problem where many of us are not really
in danger but we are feeling isolated
with feeling disconnected in this
supposedly ultra connected world
sure digitally we've never been this
connected I would accept that there are
amazing things about technology I would
accept that but it's a real deep
meaningful human connection I think
there's a pretty strong case to say been
never been this isolated yeah I think
that's accurate
I mean there's a lot to talk about in
what she just said
that was a brilliant monologue I
appreciate that I think what generally
happens is that individual that came
into your office would go into would
either not seek help or in the event
that that person has the wherewithal the
seek help would go to a practitioner and
at least in the United States the system
is set up wherein that doctor would only
have 15 minutes with that person and
it's a setup
rigged to diagnose and prescribe and
that person would leave with some kind
of antidepressant medication most likely
and would then consider themselves
depressed or clinically you know having
some kind of mental malady without the
tactile kind of real-world practical
solution that you would implement
because you had the opportunity to
provide that person with a little bit
more bandwidth the the setup is the same
in the UK right we have 10 minute
appointments so this was over the course
of two appointments because I did some
tests came back yeah sure it wasn't just
ten I probably ran late and I'd probably
did fifteen to twenty minutes but I am
passionate that actually yes the system
is not set up to make it easy to do
these things
I absolutely recognise that and it's a
common theme that doctors will say I
will also say but it is possible it is
possible and it's possible when you
listen you need time to listen for sure
and I'm not don't get me wrong I can't
do that in every case
I have there obviously in that sort of
system you have to pick and choose which
ones you're gonna go deep on when do you
pick up that actually this person may be
receptive to this because you can make
the case that a patient comes in like
that they're not going to listen what
what the doctor gives them a
prescription to see a friend once a week
what kind of prescription is out what
kind of doctor are you
but of course I don't do that in every
case I do that where I feel it's
appropriate but the reason he did it I
believe is because I listened I did not
judge him I offered a number of
solutions and I said look would you be
interested in this and when I when I
teach doctors about you know for what if
a better term lifestyle medicine and how
we can use Lysanne know these prevention
but also as the treatments for many of
the chronic conditions we're seeing I
say to them the number one skill you
need as a health care practitioner in my
view after nearly 20 years of seeing
patients is can you listen
non-judgmentally I can you be
compassionate because I think when you
when you can do those two things
opportunity and option start to rise to
the surface and I'm super proud of that
case but that case actually taught me
more than it probably taught him mmm
because I have applied that with other
people it's like this book right after
you've read this book lost connections
you probably know Johan I know you heard
again probably my most listen to
podcasts a boys have one with Johan yeah
I mean that's the entire thesis of his
book right there yeah but people don't
get I don't think that this is
biological it feels a bit trivial
friends you know what you know this we
are social beings we're wired to be
together you know other oh yeah you know
you mentioned touch before right so
there was a chapter on touch in this
book and again this is something I was
super proud of because I devoted a whole
chapter to the importance of human touch
can I expand on that yeah so I I was
filming a new BBC One documentary about
a couple of years ago and as part of it
we ended up at Liverpool John Moores
University and a match up called
professor Frances McGlone who is
probably one of the world's leading
researchers in touch and he was telling
me about his research and I was
literally getting mesmerized
blown away by I thought I don't know
anything about this this sounds buttery
incredible this is starting to connect a
few dots for me in my head and so you
know dive into the research wrote the
chapter about it but there is something
primal about human touch and it links to
that story we just mentioned about us
being social beings so there are two
kinds of touch nerve fiber okay we often
feel that actually touch nerve fiber is
there so if you were to touch me on my
forearm I would know oh yeah Rich's
touched me on my forearm so
geographically telling me where I'm
being touched but there was another type
of nerve fiber as well that is super
super important there's a fast nerve
fiber which tells you where you mean
touch and there is a slow one right
let's use pain as a way of unpacking the
something it's a little easier to
understand with pain so if you're in
your kitchen and you are cooking
something and you hold a boiling hot pan
by accident instantaneously what happens
you feel the burn in your hand but there
is actually a little bit of a delay
before you actually feel it exactly you
initially you let go right straight away
within a milliseconds you will let go of
that pan that is the fast pain nerve
fiber telling your brain I have been
searched this is a problem move your
hands a few seconds later is when the
emotional qualities of that pain comes
and you might feel other affronted that
actually that has happened even a better
example I guess is a kid falling down I
remember what my daughter was four years
old and she tripped in the back garden
and she fell on her knee so initially
she's like rubbing her knee she's not
crying she's a bit bemused she's just
rubbing her knee about four seconds
later the coin kicks in yeah every every
parent has seen that in the child that
delayed response exactly now who tied up
to what where I was going before when we
were talking about he was being social
beings what is amazing about these CC
afferent nerve fibers is that the bulk
of them are on our upper back and our
shoulder right so on an eeveelution
level why would nature put so many of
these nerve fibers
on our back mm-hmm right and a place
that we can't actually easily touch
human touch is not a sentimental human
indulgence it is a biological necessity
and when you dive into the research you
can't come up with any other conclusion
hmm that's super interesting yeah and
we're we're in a dearth of that right
now
yeah I think we're all starving for real
real human touch you know I think we
have to you know bifurcate sexuality
from this and just focus on you know
what it means to be connected to another
human being you know what does intimacy
mean you know I think intimacy gets
conflated with sexuality but to be
intimate with with another human being
is the stuff of life and when we're
separated from that we we we D evolve
mentally emotionally spiritually and
ultimately physically I mean forever
flex on my own behavior as a doctor like
10 years ago if someone came into my
surgery in my clinic and if I had to
deliver bad news I know what I used to
do I'd pull my chair closed I would
lower my tone in my voice
I'd put my arm or my hands on that upper
back of shoulder and I would deliver the
news these days I don't do that I am
also a little bit scared that it is
inappropriate now to touch someone it is
inappropriate to touch a patient and
just to be clear of course in many
occasions it is but have we lost
something I mean that's a rhetorical
question yes we have lost something but
it is so fundamental and that's why one
of my recommendations that I make is you
know again trying to present the case
then give somebody something actionable
is keep a touch diary write write a
diary of how many times in a week you
have meaningful appropriate human touch
right and my challenge is look at the
number and see if the nets but you can
double it just try it and see what
happens but you know rich there's also
some really fascinating research that
kind of kind of support
in the NBA a few years ago they did a
study and they showed that that the
teams who touched each other more at the
start of the season who had more
physical contact with the teams who
finished higher which is incredible now
look I'm not trying anything that it
that's someone even thought of doing
that but this stuff is primal if a
waiter or a waitress gives you the check
in a restaurant and they put their hand
on your shoulder when they do it you tip
more right that has been shown in other
research the point I'm trying to make is
that this stuff is importance we are
starving when it comes to human touch
and it's not as hard as we think it is
like I met you today what do we do we
had a hug right that was nice right I
encourage you know my guy friends we now
hug a lot more since I dived into this
research like a good mate in mine Steve
yes sorry about this buddy but I
probably wouldn't have you know in the
past we might just very very unbraid of
well I got it is probably probably 27
days in LA here in Southern California
we hug all the time yeah but it feels
good right last time I met him he came
to my house a few weeks ago we we hugged
and it feels good and I think this stuff
you know that the conversation around
health
I feel gets overly polarized regarding
food and movements now I am not for one
minute saying that these things are not
important but I think there is far too
much focus on them personally at the
expense of other factors and here's the
funny thing about stress right and this
is what I really figured out as I was
unpacking the book and once again often
our food choices often our movement
habits often why we do certain things is
because of the stresses in our life so
what happens in January every January in
the u.s. in the UK nuuuu time to get
healthy right
so what are the two communist things I
see people doing in my clinic I want to
reduce sugar or I want to reduce my
booze right there's a to commerce things
so what is the pattern that I see is
this
for a week for two weeks maybe for three
weeks
willpower gets them through so yeah
getting sugar out the house I'm not
gonna have it this year's gonna be
different so I'm gonna be like the last
few years this year I get on top of
things
same with alcohol you know I'm not gonna
drink yeah I've I've overdone it over
Christmas and New Year that's it now
amen I'm sorting my life out one week to
three weeks then there's how much stah
like weed back in and my view on that is
in a lot of cases it's because the sugar
or the alcohol was serving a role in
someone's life of course of course
I know it's super obvious to say it but
what they're doing is they're and I do
we some explaining is I think people
will be listening to this and somebody
there it's gonna go yeah that's me
actually I do that every January but I
can never get past January the 14th and
if you are using sugar or if you're
using alcohol or if you were using
anything to soothe the stresses in your
life I think many people are going to be
very limited in the change they're gonna
make unless they address the underlying
stresses addressing underlying stresses
then you no longer need to engage in the
same behavior I'll give you another
example I had a patient who was a I come
I'm his job he was sort of some sort of
managerial position in a company and he
came to see me for you know whole
variety of different reasons the point
was is that when we looked at his
lifestyle it's quite clear to me what
was happening so he would drink a lot of
alcohol and it was affecting this
relationship it was affecting the his
sleep it was affecting his performance
rights but he wouldn't you know he
wouldn't drink every day but what would
happen when you looked at as weak as he
would start drinking on a Wednesday so
what happens when you unpack his life
Wednesday just after lunch he has to
present a team meeting he finds it
incredibly stressful so by the end of
Wednesday's work he is super amped up he
goes straight home and he wants to
unwind so we open some bottle of wine
has a glass one glass turns into to two
thousand two three and before you know
it Wednesday
he has a whole bottle of wine therefore
doesn't sleep well wakes up tie
feeling a bit angsty needs more caffeine
to get him through by default of that
happening he's quite anxious throughout
the day feeling stress throughout the
day because he's drinking caffeine all
the way into the afternoon you know he
then drinks more alcohol than Thursday
effects of sleep and this pattern
continues whereby come Friday it's two
bottles of wine come Saturday is two
bottles of wine and Sunday he spends
just recovering for the week ahead now
what did I do
of course as you well know which there
are multiple things at play here but in
this particular instance I helped him we
sort of unpacked this week and I helped
to say hey look you know it seems that
on Wednesdays things start to go wrong
so is there something else that we can
maybe think about doing to de-stress and
he said well you know we've looked at a
few options there was a yoga class I was
just gonna say she got yoga class right
after you should we should swap places
man you guys oh my go ahead I'm coming
wave in their study California so what
happens next is that he goes okay fine
so Wednesday straight after work before
going home what does he do he goes to
yoga now he was a little resistant but
again he was seeking help so he came to
see me so he goes to yoga
within weeks everything changes when he
comes back he reports what happens on a
Wednesday now he relieves that stress at
Yoga he goes home feeling calm feeling
presence changes his relationship with
his wife he still has a glass of wine on
a Wednesday night but it's one glass
doesn't affect his sleep as much he
feels good on Thursday again he'll have
a glass of wine on the Thursday not the
whole bustle and you know ultimately
over the course of a few weeks it
completely transformed things so that
was the trigger point for him in the
week so I hope that people listen to
this someone's gonna identify in their
own life and go yeah wait a minute yeah
this is that's like a similar person for
me maybe if I can manage my stress in a
slightly different way maybe those
knock-on consequences will be different
and so look these are individual cases
but they apply to all of us in many
aspects of our life yeah I think
basically what you're doing is you're
telescoping up on
on the whole situation and trying to get
at the root causes of these things so
that the solutions that you're
implementing are taking into
consideration that downstream impacts of
these behavior so instead of just saying
well don't drink a bottle of wine you're
looking at what is causing the person to
make that choice in the first place and
then you see the domino impact either
way either positive or negative to what
happens to that which i think is I mean
that's that's the way to address these
things you know this has come from
experience because what what is all
public health messaging it's you know
eat less of this move more you know
you're drinking too much alcohol you
know doctors over and over again tell me
the service all great dot strategy but
you know patients just don't do what we
tell them to do I would argue that that
phrasing in itself needs shifting ijen
generally get really good compliance
with my patients like I do not say
that's a boast I'd say that because I
really think that when you communicate
effectively with them right people want
to change people don't want to come in
and not follow your advice people not
want to take half a day off work to come
and sit in a waiting room wait for 20
minutes whilst your running lights come
in and see you so that they can ignore
your advice people want to feel better I
that is my number one belief in my job
is that people fundamentally want to
feel better they don't really want to be
there so let me help them feel better so
what is leading to that idea that
patients don't take the doctor's advice
is it in the delivery in the in the
manner in which these practitioners are
trying to advise the patients like where
is that communication break down
look I think conventionally if we look
back over the last 30 40 years that has
been a certain tradition in medicine
this very paternalistic relationship I
have a problem I can tell the doctor
he's gonna he or she it's gonna figure
out what the problem is
give me a diagnosis and then give me
some form of prescription usually a pill
to take to get rid of it and again I
would make the case that maybe 30 40
years ago that works super well like
you were coming in with an acute problem
like a pneumonia and you know you're
coughing you can't sleep you've got
sweats hey doctor help me
you know they listen they may take some
tests hey you have gotten ammonia that's
the overgrowth of this bug I've got a
pill for you that is gonna kill that bug
and you will be better why that approach
has worked and it still does work of
course there are unintended consequences
off that any example I gave but that
approach I think does work in the whole
medical system as you've alluded to
already is set up around that model hmm
we are not set up a to look for root
causes people on line will say yeah we
are this is all nonsense you know all
doctors look for the root cause I'm
sorry but I disagree because I know what
our training is and we're not really
trained to look at it because I don't
think we had to in the past so hey I
don't think we're trained to do it B I
don't think the system is set up in a
way that allows us to do it and look if
you are a busy tired stressed-out doctor
and you have like in the UK a NHS GP
we'll see between 30 and 50 patients a
day right I get it right you're sitting
there you've got five people waiting
outside the easiest thing the world aids
to give a prescription because you can
get that done quickly and run on time
and start to build through your backlog
but also I think the way we're taught
and the way often in that rushed setting
that we deliver this information is I
think it's I think it's destined to fail
like if you have a patient right who
comes in type 2 diabetes is the obvious
example to use right the patients in
front of you and you've got their tests
right let's say they're coming in for
some blood tests they're trying to
figure out what's wrong with them why
they're so tight you run some blood
tests and they've got type 2 diabetes
but they don't know this so I actually
do this at roleplay the end of the
course that I teach the dancers to
demonstrate just how different these
things can go so the conventional one is
this patient comes in knots on the door
hey Brian how you doing yeah doc you
know what I'm feeling nakid I've got
these a blood test
I wonder if I could get the results yeah
sure so without looking at them looking
at the computer looking at the screen
again yeah you know you have got
something called type 2 diabetes right
that's a chronic illness
it's a bit of a problem because we don't
get on top affair it may lead to heart
attacks and may lead to amputations in
your leg it's the Communists cause of
blindness in this country so we really
need to go on top of it now the good
news is we've caught it I've got some
drugs for you we're gonna start you
today on metformin normally within a
couple of years when he's at a second
drug sometimes we don't have to go into
them with your injections but don't
worry we've got it all under control
I'll get you seeing the diabetes nurse
and we'll get this stuff licked okay
Brian's in shock as he gets up and walks
out the door I was like hey but also
Brian you know if you can lose a bit
away and go to the gym that would help
as well okay so Brian walks out yes
you've given the lifestyle advice but
what does he take away he takes away
that what 99% of that conversation was
that we didn't mention lifestyle and
mentioned this drug and that they've got
this under control for me cool but I can
keep going doing what I'm doing if you
that sounds like I'm I'm making this up
as an extreme example I can guarantee
you that is how some of these
consultations go down there will be
people listen says who have been in that
conversation now I'm not having to go
with the doctor because I do recognize
that things are challenging but what
about the same scenario where Brian
comes in you make eye contact with him
you don't look at your computer screen
you have a conversation with him part of
what he's concerned about and then you
say hey look something actually has come
up Brian do you know anything about
blood sugar a little bit you explained
how your blood Sugar's a little bit
higher than we would ideally want now
it's actually gone into the range of
something that we call type-2 diabetes
do you know what that is no dot so I
don't know what that is okay look it's a
condition that actually it doesn't
develop overnight you have not just got
this in the last week or the last few
months this has been going on in your
body for maybe five years maybe even ten
years this has been building up now look
there are a couple of options yeah there
are some drugs that we sometimes need to
use but if you wrote open to this I can
help you look at your life Psalm and try
and figure out with you what are the
various factors that may have led to
this are you interested hey Doc yeah if
you can let me know what I can do
that'll be amazing and if you go down
that road and you spend the time connect
singing and spend the time explained to
them what they can do and what they feel
is achievable I think even within 10
minutes you can get good results but
this is communication yeah right so why
aren't medical schools training doctors
to better communicate with patients
particularly if compliance is an issue
it seems like that should be part and
parcel of what it means you know to be
trained as a doctor like you're gonna be
you're gonna spend your entire career
communicating with patients telling them
what to do what's wrong with them etc
shouldn't there be a there's just
there's a skill to that right to do it
effectively yeah you know one of the
things I'd say from certainly when I was
going through med school applications
and from what ends and it's not really
changed that much although they have
tried to evolve that is not all anywhere
and literally how you are assessed it is
what are your grades right what is your
interview right now I guess an interview
on some level is looking at your ability
to communicate I get that but I think I
think the health landscape has changed
what we needed in doctors first years
ago is frankly not what we need in the
bulk of our doctors today it hasn't
moved on and therefore the skill set
that a doctor requires in the 21st
century is fundamentally different in my
eyes and as the skill sets are needed in
the 20th century so it is about saying
yes we should be assessing it I think
that's important but also we should be
looking at can we train it like I think
you probably can train it you can teach
people some skills of how you do it how
do you actively listen how do you not
interrupt the patient's story you know
basic things that frankly I would argue
it's not just about me to tonsure if you
want to communicate with your partner
with your wife with your children yeah
it's the same skill set so given that
most of what we now see as doctors is
driven by a collective modern lifestyles
I say 80% is driven by Colette's and
modern lifestyles well doesn't not stand
to reason that actually these sort of
life skills that we need to go to
communicate
they are probably top of the tree when
it comes to being a dancer yeah
well I think it is changing slowly we're
seeing the growth and the advent of
functional medicine and you know there
are more and more people like yourselves
who understand this and art and are
stepping into a new way of practicing
medicine so I'm hopeful in that regard
but it does seem like there needs to be
some systemic changes and updating the
education and also the continuing
education right I mean you have to do
all this continuing education all the
time like couldn't that be built into
that as well
I mean rich what I'm trying to do to
help this problem is because I was
talking about it in the media for years
so I'm saying this is a problem and we
needs to change this and I was thinking
yeah but what do you do it's all about
talking about it but then what is the
solution I thought you know I've
hopefully inspired millions of people
with my TV show showing that all these
chronic lifestyle driven conditions can
absolutely be turned around are
certainly dramatically improved by
making small changes to key areas in
your lifestyle then I thought with a
colleague of mine dr. a in Pangaea we
were like you know what should we just
set up a course should we just create
one and we did it and we've created the
first in the UK and Europe it's a very
first course called prescribing
lifestyle medicine that is accredited by
the Royal College of GPs now that is
important because it gives it gives a
certain gravitas to the course it gives
it a stamp of approval that people may
not otherwise give it and it was a very
hard to get accreditation we had to jump
through a lot of Hoops we probably had
to compromise various aspects of the
course that we ideally want said but
nonetheless we've done it and we have a
95 95 more than 95 set of attendees so
far I think it's the best course I
attended highly recommend it to their
colleagues and we have not just had
primary care practitioners we've had
consultant cardiologists come
psychiatrists nurses pharmacists because
this is a problem that is systemic in
medicine now we probably train nearly a
thousand a thousand healthcare
professionals so far in the past 18
months
and we've got big plans on how to expand
that now people always say you know what
it's like you do anything and there's
naysayers is like oh that's fine but it
should be compulsory in medical school
oh that's fine but you're never gonna
make change like that and I'm like well
hold on a minute
five years ago this course didn't exist
yes in didn't have any credibility this
year we've got fully accredited course
where people can come and get their CPD
points that is progress every single
event we invite some medical students
for free to come they come give us
feedback we are talking to medical
schools this is how change happens
I'm not saying we'll get there right I
don't know if we'll get there but this
is my effort to try and contribute to
this process to say hey look this this
course is fantastic please come if
you're interested but you know here's
the problem rich we're still relying on
a doctor who has an interest who is
prepared to give up a Saturday and pay
the money to come and train the course
right so in many ways your your your
only attracting the people who've got
that interest right yeah but you started
you know and you got to fan the flames
of positive change yeah right this is
this is forward progress so yeah and so
hopefully in five years time this will
be a part of a medical school training
or it will be compulsory we can only
hope right well let's drill down into
stress a little bit more deeply this
book opens up with you saying listen
sixty to eighty percent of the people
that come into my office have some kind
of stress-related condition the World
Health Organization has qualified stress
as the epidemic of the 21st century like
this is something that we really need to
look at stringently and figure out
protocols for richer essing and I feel
like the word stress is used very
cavalierly like well we're all stressed
stressed out I'm anxious or whatever but
perhaps it might be beneficial to like
define the term like when we say stress
like what do we actually mean and what
is happening biologically
physiologically in the body when we are
under this form of duress I mean I would
agree with you the term is slightly
problematic I think we do use it there's
common parlance now not a day goes by
where you
do not hear the term right you talk to
her buddy not spoken to in a while hey
mate how you doing your yeah yeah me I'm
okay not too bad a little bit busy a
little bit stressed but I'm okay it's
it's becoming that normal and so I guess
taking about 30,000 thought of uther
mentally what stress is because stress
is different for every single person it
is a perception it is perception when
your body feels that it's under threat
that it is in danger
that fundamentally is what I think
stress is now how do you explain that
because that statistic you mentioned and
it comes from the Journal of the
American Medical Association 2013 there
was a paper where they did a little
study and they said that up to it's
actually 70 to 90 percents between 70
and 90 percent of all conditions that
our primary care doctor sees in any
given day is in some way related to
stress that's bananas that is bananas
but I'm gonna explain why I think it is
quite easy to understand when you
understand what the stress response is
so let's go back again 2 million years
right 2 3 whatever we go back a couple
of million years ago and understand how
our stress response evolved so we were
again in our hunter-gatherer community
getting on with our business doing what
we need to do and a wild predators
attacking or approaching we get scared
in an instant our stress response kicks
into gear so what happens then well the
series of physiological changes start to
take place that are designed to keep us
safe so I can't list them all but let's
go through it through some of them your
blood sugar starts to rise great that
means you're going to deliver more
glucose to your brain that is fantastic
in that in that threat scenario your
blood pressure starts to go up so you
can deliver more oxygen to your brain
your amygdala that's the emotional part
of your brain right that becomes hyper
reactive so you are literally hyper
vigilant for all the threats around you
your blood starts become more prone to
clotting so that if you were to get
attacked by that lion and that predator
you're not gonna bleed to death your
butt's gonna clot that's gonna keep you
safe these are very very smart
complex mechanisms that are designed to
keep us safe the problem is quite simply
is that now in the 21st century many of
us are having our stress responses
activated not to wild predators but to
our daily lives to our email inboxes to
our to-do lists to the fact that we've
got competing demands at work to the
fact that two parents are working and
someone's trying to rush home to pick up
the kids the fact that actually we're
living separate from our family so we're
having to do all the childcare ourselves
we don't have grandparents around us so
the fact that we may have elderly
parents now we're looking after as well
as looking after a young family form
many offers that is activating our
stress response so what happens
well those mechanisms that are so
helpful to us in the short term this
starts what can problematic blood sugar
going up it's fine for thirty minutes if
your blood sugar is going up day-in
day-out
well that leads to fatigue obesity high
blood pressure and ultimately type 2
diabetes just from being stressed and I
go back to saying what I said before
what the whole conversation around
health is dominated by diet and
movements talk about type 2 diabetes
it's all about which dietary tribe you
subscribe to I can tell you that stress
is a very very key player when it comes
to your blood sugar and I have put in
many cases to talk to Darby since
remission yes I change our diet for sure
but when the diet plateaued the way I
got the blood sugar lower was by
addressing their stress levels so blood
sugar problem helpful in the short term
harmful in the long term blood pressure
again same thing great if you're running
away from a tiger great if you and your
spinning class in the gym it's an
appropriate response to that stress or
but if that's happens your email inbox
has a problem what about your emotional
brain right the amygdala I just said
when you are trying to escape a predator
you become hyper-vigilant to all the
threats around you that is appropriate
if you go to downtown LA tonight and it
is dark and you are walking down a dark
streets and you think somebody is
following you you know what you want
your amygdala is going high alert you
want to be hype of
all the threats aren't you if that's
happening day in day out to your life
that's what we call anxiety right so
suddenly this very complex mechanism
when you simplify it right down we can
start to see why up to 90% of what I see
as a daughter is in some way related to
stress but what about the things that is
switches off right we've spoken a bit
about relationships so libido is a big
problem these days I've been practicing
for nearly 20 years I'm seeing more
cases of low libido now than I've ever
seen not a week goes by where I don't
see a young male in their twenties
complaining of low libido this was not
happening even five years ago certainly
in my practice there are many factors to
consider the stress is probably the
biggest in my view again go back to
million years you are running away from
a threat in that moment you need to
prioritize survival you do not need to
be able to chill out and procreate with
your partner right so your body switches
it off right it it all it almost sounds
overly simplistic but I love simplicity
because when you understand it simply
you start to realize hey I understand
now why anxiety why blow memory by poor
concentration white insomnia why low
libido why hormonal problems why obesity
why type 2 diabetes can all have stress
as a key player got problems right last
Mintel survey in the UK showed us that
80% of UK adults have complained of some
form of GI problem in any given year
right now food of course as a fat sir
but I would argue the stress is a bigger
factor because what happens again just
like libido if you're running away from
a lion you don't need to bail to digest
food just get switched off just like
that and one thing that I've discovered
in my practice for maybe the last two
two-and-a-half years a lot of people
feel that they are reacting to certain
foods and I say that that they are
reacting there are intolerant to certain
foods and I have gone through in many
years asking people to maybe avoid
certain foods for a short period of time
as a trial then reintroduce and see what
happens but what I've discovered since
I've really dialed in to stress
is sometimes people are actually not
reacting to the food they're reacting to
the fact that they're eating in a
stressed out state so when I teach some
of my patients breathing techniques and
I say look you really need to have some
sort of switch off between your work and
your eating I am NOT casting judgment on
anyone I also often will buy my healthy
organic whole food lunch and I'll still
be working and doing my emails whilst
doing it right but you got to understand
you might be eating the right thing but
if you're not eating it in the right way
there could be a consequence and some of
these patients no longer react to those
foods when they've changed their state
before they eat which literally was
mind-blowing to me because those
patients in the past I had us and Sue
would move that food for a period of
time so it is so so powerful and I kind
of reflect on the French when I think
about this because there is this this
whole French paradox right you've heard
of this right it's right well they eat
all these crazy foods and and they don't
have the obesity problems and the
chronic disease problems that we have
and so why is that is it their destress
lifestyle they take you know it's you
know their meal times are sacred and
elongated compared to you know what we
do here in America so same in the UK
look I I've recently been thinking about
this a lot because there are multiple
theories why the French paradox exists
but would the knowledge on Nanoha was
stress i would have to say that there's
a very powerful case to be made that
actually the way they are eating means
that actually their food is gonna have a
different impacts on their body it's
gonna do it's gonna do something
different if you prioritize a 90 minute
lunch break where hey you know what it's
lunchtime we're not doing that call with
clothes in the computer we're sitting
down we're chilling and we are now gonna
have lunch time right of course when you
understand the stress response it is
gonna do something difference and I
actually had an interview with a French
journalist last week as my it's good my
my first book has just come out in
France and I asked her at the end about
interview I said hey look can I ask you
is does that still go on I've spent a
lot of time in France
for skiing for sure but I was saying
does that silicone yeah by and large
that is still what goes on now in some
of the heavily urbanized places like
Paris and some of that companies where
there's a lot of international people
working there it is starting to get
eroded away which kind of makes sense
but I don't know I find it's so
interesting well I get the the idea that
when you're in a stress state it
restricts blood flow to your digestive
system but what is the impact on the
microbiome or why would that lead to
some kind of allergic reaction to a
certain kind of food yeah well first of
all I'm not saying true allergy we've
got to be very careful that we
distinguish allergy from intolerance
there's a very different biological
mechanism said you know I think it's
important just to clarify that if you
have a true allergy that when you eat
some food you get you know you get red
cheeks and your lips start to swell
I'm not saying in that instance but I
think some of these milder in tolerances
or not say mild many things happen your
microbiome changes with stress it's not
just food that impacts and your
microwave your stress levels do that has
been shown time and time again your
digestive enzymes so in order to digest
food whatever is you're eating you need
the presence of certain digestive
enzymes to digest that food if you are
switching off as a very broad a non
precise term your digestion the lovers
of digestive enzymes go down so it can
affect multiple different organ systems
it can affect various different things
in your guts I have found over and over
again now not only for intolerance says
that with gut problems I am more and
more focusing on the stress around how
they eat I'm getting great resource from
doing it I had a patient right who had
Crohn's disease right so Crohn's disease
for people who don't know is one of the
inflammatory bowel diseases people often
have severe stomach cramps that will
often have half ago so toilets may be up
to 1520 times there'll be blood they're
very very physically unpleasant socially
unpleasant a few years ago I had a
patient who was under the
gastroenterologists
she had tried the various drugs they
didn't work that well for she didn't
like the way that they made her feel so
she ends up at my door I stopped trying
to help her now granted I did start with
diets I thought okay let's see if we can
change some things let's see what
happens and we got a bit of an
improvement for sure and she was feeling
motivated and inspired of that okay this
is great you know I finally getting some
control over this condition then I don't
see her for a little while that she
plateaus she comes into seeing me I
hadn't seen her maybe in six months and
I'm talking to her and she's like dr.
Chad you got to do something um what
else do I need to you know do what what
do I need to add my doubt what do I need
to cut out she was talking really fast
and I started to start to unpick her
life a little bit and it was really
clear to me I was just trying to picking
up on this the sense of background
anxiety she was rushing around she was
like many of the female patients I see
in my practice they were so caring they
were nurturing she was looking after her
husband she was looking after the kids
everything she dinner her life was for
somebody else and she was not doing
anything for herself and there was many
things to do but the first thing I
started off with her was with I said
look I know you want me to give you some
more advice on your diets I know you
might want me to refer you to a
nutrition professional maybe to go deep
into this but just hear me out I think
that's not the lever to turn at the
moment I think the background stress
that was in your life are playing a role
here and I wonder if we could try
something that she was resistant because
in her head it was all about diets so
she wanted more dietary advice and I
said look all I want you to do is I want
to take I want you to take a bit of time
for yourself every day just 15 minutes
right so this is not deep breathing
before a meal this is just saying look
do something for yourself 15 minutes a
day and if you can once a week on which
do something that you're really really
passionate about that you've always
wanted to do and you've never done
anyway
so we also did what's called an MS Q and
medical symptom questionnaire so I
scored the level of her symptoms she
goes away a month later she comes back
she feels like a different person her
symptoms have gone down by 50%
it's 50% now she still has Crohn's
disease
she still has symptoms it's just
significantly better I said what have
you been doing so well you know what
every morning when I drop the kids at
school I now part the car leave my phone
in the car and I go for a walk in the
local park for 15 minutes okay great
what else do you do doc I've always
wanted to do salsa dancing always I've
never done it would you give me the
cakes every Thursday night I go to a
saucer class now this was just a month
rich but I have father doubts I've seen
what's consequently happened what does
this tell you this tells you that there
are multiple facets going on in
everybody's life that can impact every
organ system in the body I have not got
rid of her condition
she still has Crohn's disease but it's a
damn sight easier on her and easy to
manage now that she started to lower her
stress level so when you ask a question
what is stress well her stress right
wasn't too many emails necessarily her
stress was the fact that she didn't have
enough passion in her life that she
didn't do anything for her that made her
feel complete that nourished her and so
when you ask the question what is stress
it's gonna be different for different
people and that is fundamentally what I
try to do with this book is as
completely as possible simplify the
topic but then have these four concrete
areas so I want the reader to be able to
identify where does stress live in my
life because you need awareness once you
know where it lives
you know what pick one of the simple
things and try for seven days see if you
feel different that is all I ask from
somewhere I mean what's interesting
about that example that you just gave is
that the stress and that woman's life
wasn't some external pressure it was an
absence of something in her life right
which is not how we really think of
stress it was the fact that she didn't
have something that was causing her that
kind of duress that was contributing to
her to her symptoms and and it is
interesting to kind of deconstruct
stress and look at the different phases
that it has and you talked about this in
the book you talk about like the MSDS
the the micro stressed doses that we get
throughout the day it's not
it's not that stress is inherently bad
it's the chronic stress or the
repetitive nature of these little micro
doses of stress that we're getting all
day long throughout our day within
moments of waking up in the morning that
culminate in this chronic stress
condition that's creating all of these
problems but that's also very different
from this thing you call the adverse
childhood experience like the AC E which
is essentially the idea that we've all
experienced traumas in our lives some
more severe than others whether it's a
childhood trauma or some experience that
you had that even though it was in the
past it still rears its head and
contributes to your to your stress
condition when it's sort of provoked
through memory or some experience that
you have throughout the day that reminds
you of it yeah you know this is one of
the challenges when I sat down to write
this thing it was how do you explain
what stress is and how do you also
differentiate these different kinds of
stresses that you mentioned adverse
childhood experiences these are you know
really significant and traumatic things
that happen you know when you're a kid
whether it's abuse whether it's maybe
you know not having parents you know
being an orphan all kinds of things that
we know impact all of your life outcomes
and I was trying to figure out how can
you describe this and then I came up
this concepts and micro stressors and
macro stress stasis and I'm so pleased
that this has taken off and like lots of
people now use that in their classes
lots of yoga stresses constantly on
Instagram and say hey look I'm using
this as a way of describing to people
the difference and I think it's a very
useful way of looking at your own life
so a micro stress those is a little dose
of stress that in isolation you can
easily handle but when they mount up one
on top of the other they start to add up
and they can sorts become problematic so
we have all got what I call our own
personal stress threshold and it will
probably vary throughout various
different days of the week depending on
what we've got going on depending on how
well we've slept how many bores we're
juggling but we have this stress
threshold so let's say you wake up in
the morning and you're feeling calm you
can start accumulating micro stress
doses
by bets and the more of them you
accumulate the closer you get to your
own stress threshold when you get your
stress threshold that is when things
start to go wrong that is when you have
an unreasonable reaction to an email
that you've received that is when you
have an argument with your partner that
is when you scream at your kids when
they haven't actually done anything
because you have passed your threshold
and I made the case that many of us have
had 10 to 15 hits of micro stress before
we've water Abdur before we've walked
out of the door in the morning so what
is the conventional not the commercial
what is a common scenario these days
okay work stressful come back I'm
knackered
I wanna unwind I don't want to go so bad
cos and it all starts tomorrow so I'm
gonna stable it on Netflix unwinding and
and numbing what is going on in my life
so I go to bed late right I set my alarm
for 6:30 in the morning because I've got
work the next day okay so you're in a
deep sleep and at 6:30 your alarm goes
off boom micro stress test number one
because waking you jolting you from a
deep sleep is a stressor on the body you
look at the time you look at which will
be on your phone you look at it you know
what I've got a few more minutes you
press snooze at 6:36
boom alarm hits again micro stress says
number two then you think you know what
yeah I better had get up now
you grab your phone whilst you're sort
of stretching in beds
I'm just look at my email man there's
three work emails yesterday I didn't get
round to doing them I've got to do that
today MSD micros Chester's number three
then you cling on to social media ah you
know as someone's been mean to me on my
last post MSD number four then you
realize oh my god I've been in bed for
20 minutes I'm running late now I really
need to get a move on and I'm not gonna
keep sort of labeling the points but you
can very easily see how before you even
leave the house in the morning you've
picked up fifteen MSDS and what does
that mean that means you are closer to
your threshold which means it's going to
take less little hits of micro stress in
the day to tip you whatever this is what
I'm so passionate about having some
downtime having some space in the
morning to insulate yourself make
you more resilient it's not just about
reducing the stress in our life where we
can I get some people live difficult
lives some people don't earn much money
they're working two jobs that is
fundamentally stressful but if you can
adopt some of these techniques and
pretty much every single tip in the book
is free and I'm super passionate about
that but if they are accessible to
everyone you know what you can apply
these tools to make yourself more
resilient to the stress so let's say
you've got a stressful life if you're
going out of a house with only to micro
stress doses as opposed to 15 you've got
a much bigger buffer before you start to
have problems and so I think that's a
useful analogy I will say though even if
you have had a macro stress dose one of
these big hits of stress like you know
like trauma of some sort like physical
abuse and I say this with the utmost
respect of course that needs processing
that needs probably to see a
professional and actually untangle that
but if you talk to a psychologist if you
talk to purpos'd they will tell you that
it is even more important in those
situations that you apply these
principles because they will help keep
you at a level that hopefully you can
manage things a bit better than without
so it really I really do believe that
this is a book for everyone whether you
have macro stressors as micro stress
doses whether you have too much stress
in your life or whether you have not
enough passion because these are
universal themes and I do think I have
simplified it right down where people
will think you know what yeah you know
what maybe I can't do that I think I can
do that yeah I think that I think you're
absolutely right and what I like about
the book is that it's it's very
practical and solution it means it's
called the stress solution it's about
the solutions right and some of these
are very easy to implement in your life
like go for a walk turn your phone off
go to bed early like you know we're very
very like simple implementable tools
morning routine whatever that may look
like for you meditation mindfulness
practices some of them are a little bit
more ephemeral I mean you're first
bucket here is purpose and you know
that's a that's a harder thing to kind
of figure out for yourself everybody has
their own relationship to purpose and
you know I feel like there's a lot of
people who live their lives relatively
untethered and don't have a sense of
purpose or what you know we both know
the the Okinawans called iki guy which
you talk about in the book and that's a
journey right so how do you help I mean
I think that's fundamental right if you
don't have purpose then everything else
is sort of a house of cards without
that's the hardest one that's the
hardest one that's why I start the book
with it because it's the hardest and I
think it's the most important because
fundamentally a life lacking meaning and
purpose is inherently a stressful life
right it just is we all know that it the
research backs it up not having a sense
of meaning and purpose in your life is
associated with much worse health
outcomes of course do we need science to
tell us that about the fact that you
don't know what your purpose is is an
added stress on absolutely so let me
clarify my view on this so I thought
okay this is all about practical
solutions
mhm I like you love that Japanese
concepts of icky guy right I do I came
across I think on a Facebook post a few
years ago and I was you know what am I
it's a Dan Buettner thing from Blue
Zones I didn't come across it we can
actually he helped kind of Usher it in
because Okinawa is one of the blue zones
and and their relationship with purpose
which they call it a key guy's
fundamental to their longevity in half
for sure and so one of my Facebook
friends I said if you're watching the
video that was inverted commas friends
and to be fair I'm being slightly you
know I'm sort of trying to make a point
which is probably not the best way of
doing it but I saw this post and she put
this thing up about he kind of saw these
four circles and the middle area was
shaded where these four things intersect
you know a key guy is when you find
something in your life to do something
that you love something that you're good
at something that the world needs
something the patient I read and I think
I read this pretty soon after my dad
died which is
very significant moment clearly for me
and I remember reading that and I
thought you know I fancy a bit of a [ __ ]
in my life you know I want that and I
saw it said with flakes on it I think
about it I thought I thought well this
could be use of some of my patients so I
started to talk about this idea with my
patients and I found many of them found
it quite stressful to think about how
can I find one thing in my life that
gives me this sense of icky guy that's
just too stressful you know I'm working
to pay the bills and to meet the
mortgage payments and to put food on my
plate feel ashamed that you can't yeah
after that and what super interested me
is in January when I when the book came
out in the UK and I was on my tour I was
in London and I spoke about this and at
the end people it was a Q&A and this
Japanese student in London put her hand
up you know so she she asks a question
she says it's Jessie I just want to add
to this that I have grown up in Japan
and I have heard about this concept of a
key guy and I found it super stress of
my whole life
as I have to live up to this esteemed
idea that is embedded in my culture and
I find it stressful and I can't do it
so that was super enjoy heard that from
my patients I also heard it from a
Japanese student in London so I'm not I
sort of pay homage to this in the book
but then I come up with what I call the
lift framework I've come up created a
framework that I think and I've seen
very very practical for people of how
they start to find meaning and purpose
in their life because I get it you
listen to this podcast on a train are
you thinking yeah meeting a purpose it's
all very well for you to talk about that
you know what your life is different
from mine so it's a very simple
framework L is for love is for intention
V is for vision is for engagement now we
don't necessarily need to unpack the
whole thing but the point about it is
you don't need to get all of these from
one aspects in your life you can get
there from different aspects in your
life but it's a simple way to stop
moving you towards finding your meaning
and purpose so what is the first L the
first L is love it's about passion right
so research shows us that regularly
doing things that you love helps to make
you more resilient to stress
and I'm saying that resilience is super
important but at the same time being
stressed out day in day out makes it
harder to experience pleasure in day to
day things so one of the prescriptions I
give people and I don't particularly
like the term prescription but one of
the recommendations I make is to have a
daily dose of pleasure you can move just
for five minutes now again just to bring
this to life I had a patient 52 year old
chap
or maybe 53 you know early fifties chap
CFO of a local plastics company writes
again comes in to see me he's worried
doctor do I have depression what's going
on I struggled to motivate myself
sometimes I can't concentrate at work I
feel quite indifferent about my
relationships you know what is going on
so as always I try to unpack different
aspects at their lives do you like your
job yeah not really you know it's so so
I have to do it and I've got a family I
need to provide for them I said okay
fine how's your relationship with your
wife you know what so so you know I
don't really see her that much it's fine
do you do you have any hobbies I don't I
fall peas pissing I kept bat late
okay what about weekends weekends I've
got to do the household chores I've got
to take the kids to their classes I
don't have time for hobbies so the
prescription I gave them the
recommendation I made some at the end of
doing this and again so that I don't get
all that it matters if I get criticized
but just so people understand I did do
the safety netting that is required of
me I didn't feel he was an active
suicide risk I didn't do all these sort
of various things that I have to do as a
doctor I did check but ultimately what I
felt was he didn't have any passion in
his life right and I said look did I
know you don't do any hobbies now did
you ever have a hobby well yeah I guess
you know when I was a kid when I was a
teenager I loved playing with trainsets
okay great do you have a choice at home
I've got one at home it's in my attic
I'm not seen if he is I said okay look
what I would love you to do when you go
home tonight is to get your twin sounds
and you've got a smirk on your face
right
yeah I get it hey I have no judgement on
people's hobbies I had a train set when
I was a kid well I thought you I thought
you were smoking on the fact that the
doctor he came to see me with a problem
he was concerned about and my
prescription was to get at his trial I'm
with you on that okay you're with me on
that okay so so he again he agrees to go
and do this so he goes away I don't see
him then it is not uncommon in general
prices in the UK for you not to be able
to follow up every single patient you
just simply cannot do that so I got on
with my job was you know do my thing
three months later I finished my morning
clinic and then we have something called
home visits in the UK where you know
normally after your morning clinic you
will then have a list from reception of
people who were maybe elderly and firm
who can't get out of the practice and
you go and visit them at home to look
after them so I was I went to the car
park to go do my own business and I
bumped into his wife I said hey hey look
you know how's your husband getting on
he said that's Jesse I feel like I've
got the guy I married back again he
comes home from work he's straight onto
his train set he's on eBay all the time
trying to buy collectors items and he
and he's subscribed so this monthly
collectors magazine now right so she's
happy wearing his conductor hat
yeah house hey [ __ ] she's happy but I
still hadn't seen him right again
roughly three months later I'm just
going through my clinic as usual and I
see his name pop up and he has had some
blood tests at a well man check and he's
coming in to see me to go through them
welcoming in and before we go to the
blood results I say hey look how are you
getting on he says doc I feel like a
different person life is great I said my
moves better I've got energy I said okay
cool you know how's your job job I love
it were they getting a lot out of my job
now how's your relationship with your
wife really really good I feel really
close to her so just like that case I
don't know how long we'd be chatting for
maybe an hour ago just like that
story about the kids who was feeling low
and who had a friendship deficiency did
this guy have a mental health problem
sure I think he had symptoms that would
be consistent I could have made I could
have labeled him and given him a
diagnosis rights
and of course sometimes that may be
appropriate although I have issues with
labels cuz I think what that does to
people that's a separate story or did
this chap really have a deficiency of
passion in his life and the remarkable
thing for me is when that passion
deficiency gets corrected not only does
he feel barren himself but everything
else in his life starts to come back
online the job that he couldn't stand
before now he enjoys the relationship
that was a bit tired and he felt a bit
indifferent abouts
now he's feeling closer to his wife and
you know this is why I'm trying to make
the case that this this live framework
is applicable it is achievable if you
are listening to this and you want more
meaning and purpose and you don't know
where to start I challenge you when was
the last time you did something you love
right if you haven't done it recently
schedule it in your diary it doesn't
need to be fancy doesn't need to be
swimrun like we did at the start right
for many of my patients I say give
yourself five minutes a day for a daily
dose of pleasure that could be going
through a walk
that could be reading a book the sense
of a podcast it could even be coming
home from work going onto YouTube
finding your favorite comedian and
laughing for five minutes so when we say
meaning of purposes on a Tanner or for
many people I disagree because if you
start with small small steps I mean you
could call them hacks I know you're not
a huge fan of the hacking worlds and I
wouldn't call them hacking in the same
sense I'd call them you want to get to a
certain destination the destination
seems too far away so let's look at a
signpost that's nearby let's just break
this down make it super super simple do
something for five minutes a day that
you enjoy do that consistently week
after week and you will start to find
other things in your life that will
bring you closer to meaning and purpose
that's just the L right but I'm super
passionate that we can all find meaning
and purpose of course it's harder this
guy I didn't find his okie guy right
this chap I just spoke about he's not
quit his job and is now living on a
beach and living his kind of this
romantic idea of what a beautiful life
looks like now
he's just found passion in his life and
suddenly his day-to-day life that was
monotonous before suddenly is vibrant
and I'm so passionate about this rich
because it's not as hard as we think it
is take small small steps small steps
are everything I mean I think what
happens is people I mean it goes back to
what we were talking about earlier but
people see read hear this message follow
your passion and it does have that shame
provoking you know unintended
consequence to it and it just seems
overwhelming and intimidating because
that gets associated with quitting your
job or you know sort of you know being a
digital nomad or like making these
massive you know seismic shifts in your
life but and and and that may be the
ultimate trajectory if you keep pulling
on that thread like maybe that train guy
is gonna reinvent himself and become
some kind of you know like toy train
entrepreneur who knows but more likely
than not it is just having the
wherewithal to set aside a little bit of
time to take a tiny step to like embrace
some aspect of what you love I mean
that's how it started with me like I
just I went back to the swimming pool
and jumped in the water you know it was
nothing more than that and it's led to
me sitting here with you and in a manner
I could have never predicted in a
million years but the tiny first step
that seems meaningless and unconnected
to ephemeral concepts like iki guy and
passion is where all of these things are
seated yeah for sure and you know this
is such a fundamentally important point
not only under the umbrella term of
stress just for just overall well-being
you know how we feel about ourselves
it's very hard to do that without
passion it's very hard to do that unless
there is some overarching objective or
direction in your life where you are
going and I get it many people don't
feel that they can have it this is why I
drill down I think so hard how do you
make this achievable how
do you bring these kind of really lofty
concepts and ideals how do you bring
them right down to something that
someone who's working in a council flat
who's working two jobs he feels that
there is no way out to something that
they can apply and you know I know this
stuff works because I've been using
these tips with real people busy people
with busy lives and you pointed it out
that's it it's not about necessarily
that first step of course that's very
important but who knows what that guy
will be doing in five years he's he's
now on the road to that destination well
there is no destination but he's on that
road on that journey towards meaning and
purpose and it starts with those small
steps mm-hmm so we are headed into
holiday season the most stressful time
of the year by the time this podcast
comes out we'll be you know more in the
thick of it this is this is the moment
where stress Peaks people are with their
relatives they're in high-stress
situations there's a lot of pressure to
show up for other people and it pushes
people over the edge so I think it would
be really helpful and instructive to
kind of provide some guidance for how
people can better navigate the
minefields of the holiday season yeah
sure you're right it is it is all over
the world I think well certainly and the
countries in which we live it's it's a
time fought with problems pressures
external pressures things that we feel
that we have to do there are so many
things that we can do but the thing that
is rising to the surface in me now is
think about downtime right we need
downtime we thrive on Downton our brains
thrive on downtime you simply cannot get
up go on your phone consume watch what
the world is giving you reacting go to
after work drinks go to all these family
engagements come back lie in bed consume
more you simply just cannot do that
without there being a consequence
you will be accumulating micro stress
tears after micro stressors and you will
go over and it will lead to family
arguments it will lead to a round with
your partner it will lead to you getting
stressed out at work and falling out
with your boss it is all the consequence
of that framework of micro stress doses
and where is your stress threshold you
need to minimize the micro stress doses
and you need to take active steps to
increase your resilience so what let's
call the simple you mention the morning
routine right I have a huge fan of
morning routines and the framework I
create for people is a morning machine
has three ends and the way I see it
mindfulness movement and mindsets so if
you want a morning routine you don't
know where to start think about those
three tabs now you can personalize them
to your own life if you have got an hour
in the morning great if you've got five
minutes you can still do in five minutes
mindfulness that could be meditation
it could be breathing you know whatever
you want can be mindfulness whatever
appeals to you movements anything you
want do some push-ups do some yoga
stretches and then mindset mindset is do
something to put you in a positive frame
of mind that can be reading a book that
you enjoyed it makes you feel good it
could be doing some affirmations like I
often do with my daughter now to really
be clear on this I have a patient in
particular who says doc these Mon
routines they sound great I'm too busy
I've got to get the kids ready I don't
have time for this she now I have
persuaded her to try it and she now
sticks religiously to her five minutes
morning routine right so my own routine
tends to be about half an hour I have
that luxury now I didn't always but hers
is five minutes so what does she do
let's break those dreams down first then
mindfulness she does deep breathing for
one minute when she gets up right she
does a breath I've taught her that I
really like all the three four five
breath when she breathes in for three
she holds her fall and she breathes out
for five now that is one breath in the
book there is a whole breathing menu
with six different breaths if you don't
like that one
don't do it choose one that you do like
so that's her one-minute breathing then
what she do for her neck
two minutes she does some Sun
Salutations
but she learned any yoga class just two
minutes
then what she does she reads a book that
she likes she keeps her she keeps five
books there and she picks one she reads
a few pages just the act of having five
minutes to herself in that morning
actually transforms the rest of her day
she this particular patient had a really
bad eczema her exmas gone down
dramatically since you start doing this
morning with scene when you understand
the physiology of course that makes
sense
stress ultimately impacts the immune
system eczema actually at its core is a
slight dysfunction of certain parts of
the immune system therefore if you can
impact the immune system you stand a
chance that you actually might be able
to reduce your xmin not in every case
but in this case so have some time to
yourself really be mindful of that and
if you find a morning we've seen helpful
start there now the next thing I'd
probably say to people is think about
how much you've moved yes we know
physical activity is important but
fundamentally if we go back to too many
years ago when we think about a stress
response what is the stress response
designed to do it is priming us for
physical activity nowadays the stresses
are coming in such a way like you know
we're sitting on our butts at our desk
and our email inbox is stressing us out
or the fact that actually on man I am
exhausted today but everyone at work's
going out tonight and then my sister's
flying into town tonight
oh man I just want to go to sleep right
so I would say have you moved enough
just ask yourself have you moved if you
haven't just make it a priority every
day to do something even if it's a
10-minute walk at lunchtime put your
phone down go outside for 10 minutes and
you will start to burn off that stress
in your body well those are two simple
things right when you're traveling if
you're traveling to go and see your
family right and this applies not on the
holiday season as well the people are
traveling to work and they're getting
stressed out use that travel time so
witty to really look after your mental
health right don't put the news on don't
listen to what Trump is just tweeted
right on your mental space own
what's going on in there use that time
to listen to relaxing music listen to an
inspiring podcast pull up the calm
meditation app on your phone and put
your headphones in and meditate for 10
minutes I am NOT asking you to do three
hours of yoga every day even though that
will help you right I'm asking you to
just think about have I given myself a
bit of time today if you are getting
stressed out at a party at your family
of that your mother is stressing you out
right your mother-in-law let's say you
know or whatever check in with your
breath it's a cliche it is the biggest
cliche just breathe if people understood
what breathing actually does on a
fundamental physiological level we would
all be practicing everyday breathing is
information for your body when you're
feeling stressed when you've got
deadlines that you're working away for
you will not realize that your breathing
will change you you will start to be
more from your chest than your diaphragm
you will breathe quicker your breasts
will be more shallow and what does that
do that sends messages to your brain
that I am in danger that there is a
problem and that gets you in a viciously
where you start to breathe faster now
the great news about that is is that you
can very easily change that situation if
you consciously change your breathing
you can change your physiology so if
that's happening you're at a party
whatever there's a work do you know what
maybe go to the restroom or go go
outside and just for two minutes
breathe do the 3 4 5 breath if you don't
like that one do a box breath where you
breathe in for 4 hold for 4 breathe out
for 4 hold for 4 I guarantee if you do
that for one minute or two minutes you
will feel karma and the way you deal
with that situation well absolutely
it will change you won't you will be
less reactive alcohol right I get it
Tommy air what people like to drink fine
I recognize that that is something
people associate with that time of year
just be mindful of the facts that
alcohol will trash your sleep right
there's no other way of saying it
alcohol trashes our sleep quality if
you've been out for a few nights on the
bounce
and you're tied you know what learn to
say no just just look you are going you
know what do I need to go to every
single social engagement or can I go you
know I've gone to two this week maybe
I'll just stay in one night and you know
I'll reset my stress threshold by having
an early night and going to bed and then
maybe I'll go out tomorrow night's if
you're out drinking maybe can you just
reduce it a little bit you know if you
like to have a glass of wine when you're
out fine
most people who drink when you talk to
them sober will tell you and I
appreciate you know I appreciate that
everyone's different on this but for
most people the enjoyment comes from
that first drink for I shouldn't say for
most for many people right there's kind
of diminishing returns after that I mean
you may have a different perspective on
there so I'm sort of yeah I have a whole
other thing on that but go ahead okay
I'm gonna say some people right right
they will find that actually their
enjoyment comes from that first drink
that's just a little feeling of unwind
from the day you know maybe have that
first drink enjoy yourself stay out and
then I don't know don't go don't go
overboard because what happens in
holiday season I don't ever really
thought about this not really been asked
this but why is it holiday season is
fundamentally your micro stress dose is
add up there are more micro stress tests
in your life so you are operating near
to your stress threshold much more than
you ordinarily would so anything that
pulls you away from that is important
yeah I mean I think the holiday season
is an exacerbated scenario in which we
become very reactive to our environment
and less mindful about the choices that
we're making because there's a lot of
expectations set by other people and we
ping-pong around like oh I have to go to
this event and there's that thing and
that my relatives are coming in and I
got to make sure that I get a gift to
this person and it is a you know that
can be a fight or flight situation but I
think fundamentally the more we can
cultivate a healthy respect for how to
say no when appropriate and how to
create healthy boundaries around
self-care
these these are the preservation
strategies for navigating these things
just because you're invited to all these
places doesn't mean you have to say yes
to all of them and I feel like sometimes
and I noticed for myself I feel like no
I can't you don't understand like I have
to go to this thing because if I don't
then this will happen and that person to
say that I Murphy we don't know my
family and you know all of that like I
get all of that but to have the
wherewithal or the compunction to say
okay maybe I do have to go to that but
let me take two minutes to just be with
myself and Bree so I can create kind of
a protective invisible boundary around
myself that allows me to be more present
more mindful and less reactive so that
when I am with that family member that
easily provokes me when they push that
button like I know that they're going to
I don't do what I always do which is
react and then create this downward
spiral of you know emotional turpitude
so that's what detachment does does and
that's what a daily practice
of just simply taking a bit of time for
yourself whether it's meditation or
breathing or just sitting out staring at
the garden where you live right what
these things start to do for you to help
you they help you get that bit detached
so when someone does potentially inflame
you you're not in a need or a moment
you've got an extra minutes ago hey you
know what I usually you know what I get
it you know she's traveled a long way
you know she didn't sleep well last
night okay I get it let's just let that
be so I think that's important the other
thing you know thinking about the
holiday season it's I gotta say it's
hard to think about it because I am
literally I've been walking on the beach
this morning I don't know what the
temperature is it's sunny outside 75
degrees out right yeah it's so gorgeous
that it feels like hard to be talking
about this but yeah thinking about it I
think over the last two years what we
have done with my wife's family around
Christmastime the holiday season in the
UK is I mean it's not a holiday scene
this is particularly my Christmas is for
us for many people this whole idea of
gift buying is incredibly stressful or I
must get everyone a gift I need you know
I mean there's so many facets to this
but we have had a very open conversation
with her family about not buying gifts
right now I get for some people it is a
fundamental
part of Christmas I am NOT trying to
suggest that that need not be the case
it was a fundamental part of Christmas
for us but we have really thought about
what Christmas means to us and really
it's a for us it's about time why we can
actually switch off and actually spend
time with people who maybe we don't
prioritize enough at other parts of the
year so we have asked everyone as I look
would you be open to not doing the whole
gift thing right a there's an
environmental component to this which is
a big thing for many of us these days
this whole idea that we're buying all
these frankly unnecessary gifts that
most people don't like what we buy for
them anyway and they go into charity
shop or they just sit in a cupboard and
they just accumulates we buy wrapping
paper and we wrap it all again
I am NOT trying to take away the magic
of Christmas for someone who's listening
to this and they love that I am just I'm
just articulating what we have done we
still do that for our kids or they were
a lot less than we used to
but with my wife's I think we've simply
we don't buy gifts right nowwhat anymore
and we you said you know what that is
reduce the stress that was so much like
those days when it's a Christmas of a
frenzy trying to rush around thinking oh
I need to buy a present that a you know
you buy something just so you can give
them the present and say happy Christmas
I check the box and then it ends up in a
landfill yeah so I think there are many
components to sort of I would ask people
think about the holiday season what is
it really about for you not not what is
it about the way you just you know gut
reactions sort of oh it is about
presence is about going out it's about
seeing my friends will you take a step
back and maybe write down actually what
is it I love about the holiday season
and I think whenever we get our thoughts
out of our mind onto paper it helps to
helps to order things helps to clarify I
mean
on another note one of the best things
about writing a book I think is you can
have all these wild ideas in your heads
but actually the active Weisinger book
means you have to order them you have to
find some sort of coherence and clarity
to them and I think you can apply the
same thing to the festive season write
down what you like out of here what it
means to you and then think about all
these engagements all these things that
you've got to do which one's actually
truly
what gives you joy about that part of
this season and I think people might
find that look I've never tried this to
anyone I'm just it's coming up to me now
but I'm thinking that might be you
suffering what for people to look at
this and go hey you know what
you know I do love seeing my family cuz
I don't see these guys much but the fact
that I go out with work for three nights
just before that and I get drunk every
night and I'm not sleeping means I go
into the funnest part of that time
already exhausted already a little bit
ratty maybe I should just prioritize the
thing that I really like about it and
not do all this other extra stuff so I
don't know people find out useful yeah
no I think that's it's super practical
advice you know I mean it's a it's a
time fraught with emotional landmines
and you know I think there's a lot of
people myself included who go into it
thinking this year is going to be
different and then I do the same things
that I've always done and I get the same
results and it's only if you're willing
to you know make those alterations and
you know invest in your well-being and
you're proactive about how you set that
schedule and that agenda and what is
important and what your priorities are
that you're going to get a different
result so based on that what are you
going to do differently this yeah I am
I'm actually taking the entire month of
December off Wow so I haven't really
taken a break like I I get to go on a
lot of cool trips to cool places but
it's generally related to some work
thing or some conference or something
like that
I really haven't taken like a vacation
let alone a legitimate break from what I
do like I've never missed a week of the
podcast years so I'm I'm gonna
completely tune out a hundred percent
for no episodes can release no we're
banking everything now we're getting all
the work done so the show will continue
to go on but I'm gonna have nothing to
do with it and I'm gonna be off email
completely so I haven't I've never done
it it's it's kind of frightening
actually like I'm looking forward to it
but I'm also a little scared I'm excited
attachment like oh if I if I what
happens if I step out of this you know
do you think do you think you can step
out without checking without getting
well that's what we're gonna find out
I'm committed
to it though and I've had like a year to
mentally prepare for it because last
year I had good intentions about doing
this but I didn't I didn't set in motion
everything that needed to be set in
motion for it to become a practical
reality and this year I took steps to
make sure that I could do that so I mean
nothing gonna be it's gonna be a hectic
October in November in order to get
everything done so that I can do that
but I'm actually looking forward to it
and I and I really need it and I think
you know wrong and part of it is I love
what I do and I've been doing it for a
while but but you know I started to
sense this feeling of of like a burden
around it you know and that's not the
relationship I want to have to my work I
want to be excited about it and
enthusiastic about it and so there's
warning signs like hey you really need
to reset a little bit and invest in and
a little bit of rest and self-care so
that you can maintain that kind of
relationship with the career that you
worked so hard to create and that you
care so much about I mean I guess what
you fundamentally talking about is
downtime yeah and I haven't taken any
downtime in years and years and years
and I'll take like it a day I mean I
most most weeks I work seven days a week
so it's not like I'm working all day
every day but I'm like it's never off
and you know I don't I don't know if
I've ever even gone on like a week
vacation so this is like very much
longer for me as a listener of your show
as well as someone who's been on for the
second time now I it's interesting
because I'm not necessarily sure that
everybody is aware of that in the sense
that you know we we all you know what do
we do on social media right we we post
the cool things that we're doing in our
life right so I may look at your feet
and go hey man she's gone on this cool
run and the hills today or he's now in
the ocean or he's training the swimming
I've not trained I need to that's the
motivation to go and train right and may
not also recognize that actually yes
you're Duma and you're sharing that but
at those other times you are working
your butt off right and I think that's
super fascinating is although that might
seem unrelated sort of song
I can't take four weeks off okay we'll
use that break it down into your own
life and figure out what is it that you
can do what is it - but as you said you
try to do it last year you couldn't
manage it but you are doing it this year
I'm so excited to hear you say that
because frankly I have no idea how you
have put an episode out every week for
seven years yeah I mean you do seasons
right which is a much more high side I
do what I don't right so what if I'd a
way of doing it
I don't I don't do it in the
conventional way I basically take August
off each year from the podcast and I say
each year it's only go for 18 months so
there's been - August in that where I've
taken off now my decision to do that is
because I have a young family you know
they're off school during that time my
life and my career has really got super
super busy over the last few years I
enjoy it but I wanna make sure I give
time to my kids once they're young so I
am not perfect I have not done it the
way I want to ideally do it but not
putting the podcasts out because I don't
have a team yet the who I can I'm not at
the stage yet where that can go out
without me but it sounds as though you
couldn't either for seven years well I
mean it's it's also been a situation of
me addressing certain character defects
around like my control freak nurse and
like yeah and how I've managed the
workload and now being in a situation
where in order to continue to do it and
and kind of ensure the best evolution of
it there are certain things that I need
to step step back from and empower other
people to do which makes me nervous as
well so this is like a growth thing for
me where I feel very uncomfortable about
it but also believe in its necessity in
order to continue doing this but let me
just make clear at the same time I'm not
a practicing doctor while trying to do a
podcast like you are this is like the
main thing that I do I mean I do other
things but this is the thing that takes
up the most amount of my time I think
you know what that's that's such a it's
really fun for me to hear that on one
level because you know it's easy we all
fall into the comparison trap you know
whether we wants him or not we look at
people we go look at this this shows you
this and this shows doing this and stuff
and one of my friends said to me the
other day
it said me you know that like you do the
podcast as well as see patients as well
as write a book a year at the moment
yeah as well and I'm thinking oh yeah
that's a good point actually it's kind
of like it's not my main thing and
you're like you're out like talking
about the stress solution but you got
another book that's about to come back
in the UK reaching out these books I was
gonna make a joke about how you have
this irrational affinity for the
number-four but yeah like you're now
you're stepping up to five and the next
one yeah look hey man look I am not
perfect I am trying to figure this stuff
out at the same time but one thing that
really excites me about hearing your
story is as well as you giving yourself
some time off I bet some magic starts to
happen right downtime is so
fundamentally important for our brains
and just to make it super clear for
people and make it really practical and
accessible in their own life right we
used to think that when we stopped
focusing on a task in front of us we
used to think that our brains would go
to sleep right but it's not what happens
there is a part of the brain called the
default mode network or the DM and that
goes into overdrive when we stop
focusing on a task in front of us so
what is that part of Brandi well it does
many many things two of the ones I think
you're hyper relevant here are the demon
helps you to solve problems and it helps
you to be more creative right so this is
the reason why so many offers come up
with our best ideas when we go for a
walk or if you like me when you're in
the shower right because you have
disconnect said you'll not focus on
something so your brain does what it
wants to do which is help you and solve
problems for you
so I would I would hypothesize and I
look forward to hearing what happens on
this timeout for you I would imagine you
are gonna get a ton of creative ideas
stuff that is have been bubbling away
there that is potentially I look I
recognize you go for a long run so I'm
sure I
has come up yeah I mean the running and
the swimming is part of that for me but
I get what you're saying and and and
that is part of the intention as well
like I have like I have other books that
I want to write but this takes up so
much time that it's very difficult for
me to carve out the amount of solitude
required to actually write yeah write
another book for sure but you know for
someone listening to this who's just
heard what I said about the default mode
Network I'd really love them to take a
minute and think how can I access that
sort of creativity and problem-solving
ability in my day-to-day life and one of
my top tips for people I spend a lot of
companies now about employee wellness
and I say one of the most transformative
things you can do is take a tech free
lunch break even if it's just for 15
minutes right because what that does is
that you fire up the dmn you will start
to you will come back more productive
your stress hours will have come down
you will have more energy problems that
you couldn't solve in the morning you
will start to solve in the afternoon and
it's such a simple little thing is you
know for whatever boat so it's a hack
right but there is incredible science
around what that actually does many of
us if we work in an office we're sitting
there typing away on our computers that
on our emails oh it's lunchtime okay
pull it out right let's have look at
Instagram that's got my personal email
right again no judgment I also do that
many much of the time but you will start
to tap in to this innate potential that
your brain has when you give it down
time I made a show for ITV in the UK
last year on stress right and what do we
do is part of that show we took three
people and we measured their heart rate
variability 24 hours a day for three
days now that is you know we don't to go
down that road but that is just a
measure of your stress levels you know
you want you want a lot of variability
from one beat to the next that shows you
are constantly able to adapt to a
changing environment around you if there
is no variation or a little variation it
means you are you have taken on a lot of
stress and you were unable to adapt so
it's a bit of a marker of resilience as
well now one of these people in
particular he was a manager at holy
about 40 years on and with a gas manager
working super hard in his company wants
to lead by example so it gets an early
works right through lunch stays late
working now he obviously applied to come
on the show because he was feeling super
stressed he was drinking a bit too much
it was affecting his relationship with
his wife I mean these are common themes
rights and we measured things we
measured his stress levels we had an
objective measurement so what was really
clear is when he was in the office he
started the day pretty low stress they
start to go up start to go up at
lunchtime they kept going up they kept
staying high in the afternoon they kept
staying high he'd leave work lates his
stressor was a pretty high when he's
coming back home and consequently there
are a lot of compensated behaviors on
the back of that all I did with him in
the week all I did was suggest to him
that he takes a 15-minute break at
lunchtime without his phone now he was
super lucky because he looked very near
his office there was a weather right so
he had a bit of nature so all this guy
does at lunchtime phone goes in the
drawer he walks for 15 minutes around a
river and comes back we did that for a
couple of weeks
weary puts the tracking devices on him
objectively huge difference stress I was
again bouncing up in the morning but at
lunchtime they almost reset back to
normal okay so he's again starting off
the afternoon very far away from his
stress threshold to use my initial
analogy in the afternoon they're not
going up anywhere near as high as I did
before and that's impacting his
behaviour in the unit so objectively
we've seen a difference that's important
but not as important as his own
subjective experience at least not to me
what did he feel it says doc you know
I've got more energy I'm more productive
in the afternoon I'm actually finishing
work early now and he's not drinking as
much and he feels closer with his wife
right so the point I'm trying to make is
that may sound super super trivial go
for a walk yeah I've heard that before
that go for an intentional walk at
lunchtime without your phone I guarantee
if you do that for seven days in a row
you will start to feel the difference
probably not even for seven days you
will start to feel the difference to say
it is such an important tip you fire up
that part of your brain and you know I
don't think it's just the walk for him
or just a downtime nature is very
powerful as well what it does for your
stress that was simply being in nature
lowers levels of the stress hormone
cortisol it is utterly remarkable many
theories but have you heard of fractals
I was just gonna say that I wrote it
down here like I was and as you were
talking I was like oh here's the moment
where I'm gonna interject about fractals
cuz that was when I said at the very
beginning of the podcast or a couple
things I did not know about that I that
I wanted to talk to you about that was
one of them oh my going on here okay
same that's because we've got such a
deep connection from actually never
having met each other apart from in a
podcast studio no it's it's and fractals
are you know fractals are a shape
they're a particular kind of geometrical
shape that you only get in nature you
get it in rivers and coastlines in the
leaves you know on trees that's where
you get frying sores and the research
suggests that when a human being looks
at a fractal something happens right the
act of looking at a fractal means that
your stress hormone cortisol starts to
come down simply from looking and being
in nature now that was remarkable when I
read it and I've looked at the research
but then as I was diving deep into this
I found some more research which
suggests that even if you can't get into
nature if you just look at a picture of
nature you also start to lower your
stress levels as well not to the same
degree I don't think but nonetheless so
there is something uniquely powerful
around nature simply being in nature
will lower your stress levels and so I
think going back to that story I think
you know if you are lucky enough to live
near some green space or you work near
some green space and at lunch time you
can go and access that great if not look
at a picture if not right what is a
section in there which I've been title
staring at a tree and I say you know
what's go outside sit on a chair
somewhere and stare at a tree for five
minutes you will lower your stress
levels and so you know but which on one
level does this not make sense that we
are you know we are hardwired as human
being
so being in nature does it actually
surprise you that much that there is
research to back up what you achieve li
feel mm-hmm no it's common sense and
what I love about basically almost
everything that you said today is that
these are all tiny little things but
there's something about the aggregation
of them that can accumulate to really
combat you know this epidemic of stress
that were that we're experiencing and I
think what happens is and I'm sure
you've experienced this with your
patients is that when you embark on one
of these small little things whether
it's a walk down to the river or the
five minutes of mindfulness practice in
the morning once you start to feel a
little bit better that creates an
emotional connection with that practice
that then encourages you to do more and
then a momentum begins and once you have
momentum it becomes a lot easier to do
these things and then you want more and
before you know it your life shifts and
I think what what happens with people is
they look at a little practice like that
and they're like well how much
difference can that make and they just
dismiss it right or or they think you
know I need to lose 50 pounds or they
set some crazy goal but then they are
short-sighted about the work that's
required or the time period that is
rational to achieve that and when they
don't achieve the results that they seek
in a compressed period of time they lose
hope and my encouragement is always to
take a longer view like I think that we
overestimate the changes that we can
make in this short period while
forsaking I think the huge changes that
can be seen a year from now two years
from now three years from now that are
achievable through these very small
bite-size little practices yeah for sure
that's the exact approach I take that
I've seen work not even in my own life
because I have a slight a type tendency
to sort of go or they're not all
outright into you know as my the
meditators I'm gonna do it an hour in
the morning yeah it's like five minutes
exactly and then I burn out yeah and I'm
like and then it's not for me and then a
month goes by before I'll just do five
minutes again yeah I think that's a
common thing yeah this is this is
and kind of demonstrated by my two hours
on YouTube swimming videos every night
so the moments right but but this is
kind of you know this is actually the
subject that I'm unpacking in my third
book feel better in five that's actually
exactly what I'm looking at is how do
you create what is the science of
behavior change and what was super fast
day for me is when you delve into the
science it actually supports exactly
what we've been talking about it's so
beautiful so and obviously you you want
it let's come back to why didn't come to
your event on Friday okay cuz you didn't
want to cover that it's alright man and
it's good I'm just I can give you a
little bit but it's but it's relevant
for this story because the reason I
couldn't come in the ends so I remember
seeing the post on Instagram and you
said you doing your first live event and
as a fan be in LA at the same time
alright I could be in LA if I just
shared things a bit I can come so I test
my buddies at hey should we all go to
Rich's event on Friday sort everything
out obviously then schedules change and
all kinds of things came in and I was
trying to I wanted to talk to BJ Fogg
right and because hey I'll be looking
into some of his research the last few
months and I thought hey I've been how
far he is from LA but maybe I can
interview him while some here and I
contacted BJ and he said hey wrong about
why you're here I'm running my two day
bootcamp and I had I wanted to attend 12
months ago but I couldn't fit it in and
I've heard rave reviews about it and so
I had to do a lot of personal wrestling
in myself what am I gonna do here and
then I looked into I thought I can cut
it fine I can leave an hour early on the
Friday I get to Elliott's at 7:30 I text
my buddy and say if I learn to LAX at
7:30 how far is the will ship it's a
combat yeah can I make it he goes man I
think you're gonna be coming this a
little bit too fine and then I was
thinking honestly I thought so you're
gonna that's gonna that's not part of
this dress solution yeah I thought
you're gonna go to boot camp
you're not gonna properly engage in it
because you're gonna be thinking about
the time there's other factors in there
but ultimately I didn't come but the
reason for bringing that up is because I
want to talk about BJ Fogg in the sense
that what I unpacked when doing his
research is that it it ultimately is
these small changes right when done
consistently that leads to those big
ones the research is out there to
support that but what fastenings and
me so much is this is what I figured out
and choose to look as a clinician who
listens to the patients and and watches
what tends to work or what tends not to
work because anybody can lose weight
over two or three weeks if they go on a
crash diet they can right you can follow
any diet book out there and you can go
all-in and you will probably if you
stick to that we'll probably lose
weights but the question then is will
that still be there in six months we'll
be there in two months and twelve months
more often than not it is not and I
found as I say to beat the same drum it
is not necessarily about those big
changes of course some people can do
that I am not trying to take away from
people's experience if that is the way
they have done it great good luck to you
but if you have struggled to make
consistent significant progress in your
lifestyle if you listen to your podcast
and you get inspiration each week but
you still feel hey that sounds great but
I don't know where to start I would say
find one thing you heard us talk about
today that resonates with you that you
think you want to do don't pick
something that you don't want to do pick
something you do want to do to figure
out how you can introduce a very small
change in that area consistently for the
next few days and then we assess and I
bet you more often than not you can feel
good about yourself your identity is
going to change because suddenly what
happens then oh I'm the kind of person
who can make behavior change I've done
that for the last five days
that has always been my approach of
patience set the bar super low set it
low patient meets that able to do it
feels good and then they by themselves
start raising the bar meditation I one
patient I asked
once I made a deal with that I said what
can you commit see she told me I can't
do meditation it's not for me I've tried
doc I said okay okay what do you think
you can do can you do 10 minutes a day
yeah maybe I said okay okay can you do
five okay okay how about this can you do
one minute a day one minute yeah yeah
okay sure I could do one minute okay
look can you commit to me now for next
few weeks you're going to do one minute
a day
okay yeah I can do one minute say I said
fine let's do one min a day I'll give
you an extra tip here the best way to
create a new habit it's to stick it on
to an existing habit that you were
already doing without thinking about it
so what do you do first thing in the
morning yeah I go out I put the kettle
on and make a cup of tea this is the UK
right so we make tea so I said okay fine
what do you do when you put the kettle
on and while the water is boiling I
probably spoke on my phone a lot bare
have a little checking the internet I
said okay fine so let's why not is this
acceptable to you every morning you are
gonna make a cup of tea you don't need
to think about that yeah why not at that
time you do one minute of meditation
she's okay I can do that
so you're not going to find any extra
time in your day to fit this in she goes
away she starts doing this one month
later she's doing 10 minutes a day right
because what happens she does it every
day for a few days she does it for a
week it's like but she's not so bad I
can do this and then that one minute
becomes two minutes that two minutes
becomes five minutes that fine it's
become ten minutes that is the approach
I have seen over and over again work for
people please if you are struggling take
something from that put that into your
practice not next Monday right make me
put into practice tomorrow you know do
it if you if this is the holiday season
when it comes out right
can somebody listen to this put this in
surprises tomorrow morning right first
thing you do so I want to give yourself
some time do woman at deep breathing if
you don't want to do meditation
yeah beautifully put the only caveat
that I would add to that involves
sidestepping the logical next question
and the logical next question being okay
you have all of these little practices
that I can do meditation sleep you know
going into nature going on a walk
turning off your phone what's the most
important one just tell me the one thing
that is the most the biggest one and you
know I'm sure you've gotten this
question right to me and I'm interested
in your perspective and then we got to
end this because we've been going
forever but to me the answer to that is
which one speaks to you which is the
thing that you feel like you are
naturally magnetized by like what
the one thing that you feel like
resonates with who you are as a person
or the person that you would like to be
like if if you're repelled by one of
these things and another one looks like
how that might be cool like maybe do
that one first okay
so what I would say to that is for other
people I would say as I always say do
not try and make a change in something
that doesn't speak to you there's no
point because you could have you're
setting yourself up for failure choose
and I've said this it talks before I've
said look if any of the tips and tools I
am recommending you don't like oh you
don't think that's not for me
fine don't do it there are so many tips
pick one that you do like that does
speak to you so that's the first way
I'll answer that question is that advice
to other people if you're asking me and
I am literally trying to Rack my head
now through all these chapters in the
book and trying to figure out which one
speaks to me the most at this moment of
time there's two that coming to the
surface and they two are jumping up
there's 12 chapters I've got two of them
are coming right to the surface of me
which is the nature chat set and the one
on intimacy those are the ones that are
really coming up for me at the moment if
I really tune into how I'm feeling I'll
start with nature I mean you've asked me
to save one thing so okay let's go with
nature I can expand on the other as well
if you want but I think nature is what
is calling me more than anything at the
moment and I've tried to figure out
where this has come from and I think
it's because I grew up in a very urban
environment right my parents were
immigrants from India they came over to
the UK to set up a better life for
themselves and for their kids and their
family and I really reflects on us what
do we used to do Matt Holliday's well
every other summer as a kid we'd go to
Calcutta in India and spend six weeks
there three weeks my dad would come then
he had to go back and work but six weeks
with my mum and my brother
and we'd play with our cousins we play
street cricket we do all this stuff in
an urban setting and it goes to the
ocean right I didn't go into forests
when we didn't do those things the other
the alternate years we'd go around
Europe might
now to take a holiday he drive us around
Europe we'd go sightseeing in all these
European cities my parents are never
left India before before the camps the
UK it was for them they wanted to see
all these European cities right we'd
walk around we stand in queues to go to
all these tourist attractions right of
course it was fun but I didn't really
get exposed to nature and I am not
criticizing my parents but as I'm
getting older and as I sort of think
about what I want to introduce into my
children's lives nature really caused me
at the moment and you know I I did it at
a week in Devon at the end of August
this year and we did things I have never
done before I got on a surfboard right I
had what 42 I have not been on a
surfboard until the summer in my life i
watch Point Break when I was 14 I was
mesmerised I I was like oh my god I want
to learn how to surf I booked a surfing
holiday in Newquay and over some reason
I think I wasn't allowed to go or
something happens and I haven't feeling
alive what I'm getting in the ocean like
this whole open water swimming that we
started this podcast with it makes me
feel alive yes I'm a little bit scared
when I'm in there still but I come back
for you think oh my god I've just done
that so the one that speaks to me the
one that I'm trying to put into practice
every day in my life is nature I don't
think anything is speaking to me more
than nature in the moments fractals
Frank's house good talking to you thanks
for having me man I love it I love the
work that you do I like I love your
enthusiasm and I feel like if I were to
pull out that Venn diagram of a key guy
that all of your that this is all
operating at the highest level for you
that you are doing what you're
passionate about that it is fulfilling a
need and it's in service to other people
it's providing you with a living all of
those boxes are checked and I think
you're exactly where you're supposed to
be and I'm excited about the new book
you're always welcome to come back and
talk to me about that as well
and thanks for sharing today that's how
many Russia sees same the book is the
stress solution the four steps to reset
your body mind relationships and purpose
available everywhere and wrong gun is
pretty easy to find on the internet
these days right so what's the best
place to direct depo if they want to
connect with you
yeah Instagram probably probably
Instagram yeah Instagram and all the
podcasts I'd say is probably the best
place Sam if you'll feel better live
more says it all right that's right man
tune it up alright until next time thank
you thanks buddy these plants fractals
[Music]